if
my
okay
yes
put it down
thank you
oh
a second
so how do they do it
wonderful
is
oh
um
good
uh
in all these years
yes
uh
distance
you
whatever
happens
now
okay
i know
foreign
is
three
okay
foreign
last time i was over there
you're a man
um
is
okay
uh
right
foreign
as well
yes
it
very good
he's already
definitely
is
um
anyone here
testing
you guys just check your microphone
please
[Music]
okay here i am trying to push this thing
ladies and gentlemen it's 10 26 we're
going to be right on the button today
because my mother watches and she makes
sure i am on time
so i don't see the representative for
house bill 1088
representative horrigan so if you're
anywhere with an ear shot please come
here
and be ready to speak
we'll be starting in
two minutes
okay
right there
members of the labor committee i'm going
to start the hearings today so i would
appreciate if everyone would stand
representative mandeville as our newest
member of labor committee would you
please lead us in the pledge of
allegiance thank you
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands
with liberty and justice overall please
uh stay standing for a moment
representative sullivan and i would like
a moment of silence today is
holocaust remembrance day
thank you maybe seated
mr clerk would you please call the roll
infant time
here
seaworth
avaloni
callum
mackie myself here
nunes
warden
morden
turcotte
prout
boyd
huff
sullivan
susie
barudi
maruti cahill
here
schmidt
toomey yeah
bouchard here
edgerton here
minimal here
thank you mr clerk
it is now 10 30 i'm opening the
hearing
on house bill 1088 and i call the
sponsor representative horgan
representative when you are finished
with your testimony please provide us
with one of those cute little pink cards
yes i will thank you i'm
a little out of breath it's not because
i have any respiratory disease i just
sprinted over from the lop to get here
in time
i do have written testimony which i
guess i'll
let me hand it down now or should i
do that after i'm finished
makes everybody's lined up pretty nicely
so
so i'm representing
because i'll take my mask off to be
heard more clearly even though i am a
member of the
mass wearing a minority in the house and
the mass wearing majority amongst the
people in the state of new hampshire so
i represent timothy horrigan
from trafford county district six the
towns of durham and madbury
i come to you to introduce my bill hb
1088 an act relative to employee
protections from cohen 19 in the
workplace
and
something of a reaction to the you've
got several bills coming up today which
are uh
what you might call anti-vaxx mandate
bills
and um
because ironically i'm the first one up
here so
and mine is sort of the flip side of
that so it's
pretty self-explanatory i guess it's
only a couple of sentences so i'll read
it here
an employee shall have the right to be
vaccinated against covet 19 and the
right to use personal protective
equipment such as face masks
and face shields while employed in the
workplace
as i'm not sure where else you where
you'd be employed but anyway as
well employed in the workplace
no employer shall discriminate in any
way against an employee based on the
employee exercising his or her rights
under this section
and this is specifically about covet 19
although i suppose
there are this could arrive with other
uh
other epidemics or pandemics in the
future
because i said it was self-explanatory
but i'll still explain anyway
if and when hb 1088 gets passed on the
law
your employer cannot fire you or
discriminate you against you in any
other way if you choose to get
vaccinated against covet 19 your
employer can also not
stop you from wearing ppe's although
there are
all workers are the right to protect
themselves and highly contagious and
highly dangerous disease which has
already killed over 875 000 americans
and will certainly soon kill over
american at the weight rate we're going
it's about um it'll uh
well anyway we'll do that with the next
couple of months
i don't specifically know of any new
hampshire employers have banned vaccines
in the workplace but i can point you in
the case of the settler school of
private school of miami who in april
announced that they would no longer hire
any facts for vaccinated teachers
um the school was widely praised in the
right-wing blogosphere including here in
new hampshire by granite brock where
several leading members of this house
regularly blog and
and um the uh there have
there have been some new hampshire
employers who
have reportedly tried to ban ppes or who
used the mass mandates during the 2021
state of emergency as explanation for
their business decision to shut down
i'm
i have several assumptions behind when i
introduced this bill which are i think
they're
generally
accepted outside the state house but
more controversial here at the state
house which is
one the covet 19 pandemic is one of the
worst catastrophes in human history so
875 000 is
i believe it's a bigger death toll than
any catastrophe anything that has
happened bad that has happened usa uh i
think with the exception of the civil
war in fact maybe even worse than the
civil war
um vaccines are worthwhile even not 100
effective or 100 safe
the uh
back three vaccines ahead i believe
they're all
very safe and very effective maybe not
100 so but i believe they
are safe they've been proven to be safe
and effective and the development
process was very careful it was
the vaccines made you less successful
the coca-19 make you less likely to
spread it to others
and the mass and the other pves are
worthwhile even if they're not 100
effective and even if
even if not all the masks that i see
some members of the community not all of
them are surgical great mass
they're actually all
being worn pretty much the right way so
which i'm
i've trouble with myself but uh still
they're not 100 effective but
whatever the difference is 90 95 99 that
still makes them worthwhile and
finally
there is no natural
or civil right to spread deadly
respiratory virus so
so basically this bill just
allows all employees to to
do what they need to do to protect
themselves against
catching the covered 19 virus so they
don't get infected themselves they don't
affect their family or also even so they
don't affect people they don't even know
so
i uh
there's committing the vote ought to
pass on this bill
if committee has any questions and i'll
uh try to answer them thank you
representative are there any questions
representative hoff
thank you mr chairman and thank you uh
representative for taking my question
my question is are you aware of any uh
statutes uh new hampshire rsas or
administrative rules that prohibit
folks from
getting vaccinated or wearing
ppe
well that um
well
the uh well those would pre-date the
cope at 19 so being vaccinated against
diseases wasn't controversial until uh
until a couple of years ago so
there are like a number of other about a
dozen other deadly diseases that we've
uh that we vaccinate ourselves against
it was never a problem until the coca-19
thing came around and came around kind
of a
strange time in our nation's history
anyway but um i um
frankly i do not know i mean you
certainly uh can check the
um check the uh law books for yourself
certainly when i drafted the bill they
didn't tell me that duplicated anything
that was already on the books so they
they
did do their due diligence and i did
mine as well so the best of my knowledge
the
statute is uh
the statute is it even if it's
unnecessary it's probably harmless but i
think i think it's necessary thank you
thank you
paul by representative mandeville
thank you mr chairman thank you uh
representative for the question on line
three of your bill it says an employee
shall have a right to be vaccinated
against uh covet 19.
um
are you aware of any examples in new
hampshire and if so
the exact number of employees that have
been denied the ability to get
vaccinated because their employer said
you can't get a vaccine
i don't know specifically i do know i
did mention that employer from out of
state and they were certainly
praised
by uh in an outlet at least one outlet
that has a lot of influence here in new
hampshire so people were they were
definitely the darlings of the
right-wing blogosphere at least for
several weeks so there presumably there
are there may be employers who would
want to ban people in fact being
vaccinated
and not to spread too much information
but
obviously i'm trying to like counter
back what i feel is misinformation by
repeating it maybe i shouldn't be doing
this but we have certainly heard many
many people in this
many members of the house come up and
say that the vaccines make you more
contagious which my opinion
and based on the studies i have seen the
research i've done is totally not true
but and somebody's inconsistent with how
other vaccines have worked in the past
follow-up
thank you mr chair um just to be clear
the acoustics for my years in here are
not good so i have trouble hearing you
um
just to be clear
are you saying that the number of
instances you know of an employer
denying an employee the right to be
vaccinated is zero simple yes or no
um i don't know whether it's zero or
some other number so that's um
which doesn't necessarily mean this is a
bad bill like so
somebody might want to do that at some
point in the future so representative
mandeville thank you mr chairman um
and thank you for testifying
i
i note that the rights
provided in this proposed bill
relate
to both both to
vaccination and also to ppe
but that the vaccination applies
specifically to covet 19. is there any
reason
it doesn't apply more generally in
respect to vaccinations in your view
that was
i was just trying to keep it as simple
as possible and as i said the other
vaccinations are not controversial we've
been vaccinating ourselves
well with going back to when we felt a
smallpox vaccine and polio and it was
never
you know
it wasn't there was never a big
controversy over it until until until
now and i cited
i just that was uh that was how i wrote
it specifically for
this uh pandemic and
this uh this virus i mean you're
certainly
certainly if you think it should be more
general um
it's your it's in your possession now
the committee can certainly uh
they want to broaden it i would probably
uh i would i would not necessarily i
would probably view that as a friendly
amendment so yeah so
any other questions for the
representative representative uh
i'll think of it a second
uh andrew and
cahill had to stand up
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
the representative for taking my
question um
sorry representative proud i had a brain
cramp for a second my apologies
um
i'm a little bit struggling to see how
um a employer could discriminate against
someone for being vaccinated is it the
intent of this bill to
prevent an employer from discriminating
someone needing time off for the vaccine
or recovered for it or just from the the
their actual status as vaccinated and
how would you
foresee an employer even knowing
someone's status if they didn't want to
disclose it
well both my main concern was
you might have an employer who would
forbid people from vaccination because
they believe the misinformation that is
being spread here in the house there
almost every day but also
i believe i mean there's already things
in the labor law that uh
that for that would make the employers
accommodate the medical needs but i mean
certainly um
if that's not clear the bill i certainly
i certainly think employers should give
people time off to get the vaccine if
they need it the actual uh
the actual jab only takes a few minutes
but you know there is you have to watch
yourself afterwards because there is a
recovery process because it's a powerful
disease it takes a powerful vaccine to
counteract it but i mean i'm certainly i
said i think employers
should allow their employees time off to
be vaccinated and allow them to take
sick time if they have a if they have a
reaction as uh as some do
follow up
um thank you so it is your intent from
establishing this right to create a new
more specific
requirement for employers to give
employees time off in these
circumstances um that's well the bill is
not quite clearly
clear where did i would i think that
would not be a bad idea so if you want
to clarify
if you agree to employ you should have
the time off and you need to clarify
that once again just as
the other representative is concerned uh
that would probably not be a sticking
point for me so you can bend the bill if
you want certainly employers
and i think just about any responsible
employer would should give you time off
to be vaccinated if you need it and they
should
some you know even this even actually
even here
at the state house we had a we had a
vaccine clinic just for
legislators and staff people i think
that's something that you know
every employer who has the capacity to
do that should do
but i have more of an answer to that but
i think specifically
yeah the main
wording is just to make sure that people
uh workers can get vaccinated regardless
of what their employer's opinion about
the vaccines might be the thing
thank you
thank you any further questions to the
representative
sing on thank you very much
i only have one additional pink card
unless there's any others for house bill
roussan chester from bedford
you committee chair and thank you
committee for hearing allowing me to
speak today i
want to start by saying that this bill
is just more discrimination
number one number two
the issue here is
if
you're going to say
you have to tell me if you're vaccinated
or non-vaccinated to have a job
then
then you're discriminating because that
is personal choice
number two or whatever um that would
this is opening up a huge camera can of
worms
if we have if we open something like
this
then we're saying we can discriminate
against someone who's hiv positive we
can discriminate against someone who's
pregnant we can discriminate against
someone who has any other kind of
condition whether by choice or by by
by virtue of health
and that's not okay
that's the bottom line i'd like to um
explain or or kind of counter some of
his disparaging remarks regarding what
he's heard about the misinformation from
the cdc website there are over thirty
five thousand systematic breakthroughs
cases each week
that was quoted from the website to
contra or from cdc at a confidential
briefing to conflicts on 7 29 22. he
talks about all the um all the the
research
and studies that he's done but i have uh
21 i'm sorry um i saw the confusion on
your face
um
um he talks about the the the all the
things that he's heard and i've listened
to him over and over and again in his in
his
meetings where he's disparaging
people that have gone through some of
these issues and he's sitting there and
shaking his head and telling and like
making noises and stuff like that that's
not okay the fact that someone's excuse
me point of order
yeah i'm sorry please speak about the
bill not about the presenter before you
who submitted the bill thank you okay
i'm i'm sorry i i happen to be
i happen to be personally involved in
this fight i am vaccine injured um
so and i don't have a dog in this i
don't have a pony in this this race
because i can't have the vaccine and i
am being discriminated against
and but i accept it because i understand
the four-letter word here is fear
the other thing is is he says that
we we've heard today through testimony
that the vaccines are safe and effective
again from the cdc website anaphylactic
shock thrombosis and
tts syndrome gilbert gbs syndrome which
is what i have
and no i didn't die but i was paralyzed
for about four months and i still have a
slight
um
problem on my left hand side and i have
some neurological damage that will never
go away myocarditis and pericarditis
reports the death after the covin-19
vaccine are rare however it's required
to report to the vare system the vast
system now has over 2 000
united states citizens that have died
from these vaccine shots i don't call
that safe and effective
do
you all right thank you for your
testimony any questions
for
the speaker
thank you cena thank you very much
teresa grinnell from loudoun
recognized to speak
good morning and i'll make it brief
thank you for the opportunity to speak
um i feel our constitution already
protects employees i don't think we need
more legislation in this regard
if someone chooses to be vaccinated or
unvaccinated is none of the employer's
business
for them to be prevented to be able to
be gainfully employed i we don't allow
employers to
there's labor laws i know that there's
this little government overreach not to
say a business owner
can't mandate that all of their
employees be vaccinated and this is the
reverse of that
that you know if i opened a shop and i'm
liberty minded say i only want to hire
people that didn't get the vaccinated i
get what he's trying to accomplish here
but our constitutional rights should
already be protecting us either way to
put another layer of legislation on top
of this is ridiculous what was
misinformation two years ago is now
being proven to be
actually accurate information we're
learning here as we go but if you have
someone who's covered recovered if you
have a jehovah's witness i love this
example jehovah's witness pregnant
mother comes running into the er to me
and she's about to go into early labor
and she says please save me and save my
baby to the best of your ability but i
do not want blood products
but blood products are going to save
your life but blood products are safe
they're proven what am i supposed to do
as a registered nurse but to honor the
fact that she does not want blood
products right and yet we've completely
reversed this in this pandemic
employers have no business
getting involved with constitutional
rights
people have the right to choose what's
best for their body
my body is completely organic
i'm a registered nurse i have not put
any pharmaceutical into my body
that's my choice just like a jehovah's
witness does not want blood products
i should not have to lose my pension my
health care my ability to be
unproductive
pursue a happiness in my in my community
right business owners have the right to
do what they want to do to some extent
but let's be honest most of our
businesses now our big businesses our
hospitals are really an extension of
government
it's not me with an ice cream shop
it's a heavily regulated
big corporation getting incentives
financial incentives
to mandate things that they want to do
that's the line is crossed when it comes
to my body
my health i have to live with gillian
beret i have to live with the side
effect
it's my choice whether i want to take
the risk reward of going in and having
covet and how my body will respond to
that just like it is for the 70 year old
to make their choice that's not
something we should be dealing with on
the legislative
so if this is going to go in it would
need to be amended that the employer
should not be able to discriminate
on me whether i'm not vaccinated
or whether someone is vaccinated you
can't have it go just one way
and in my opinion we're already covered
by the constitution we don't need to put
more layers of nonsense
it just paints us all into a corner and
it makes a bigger mess for us all to
unravel
thank you for your time
are there any questions for the speaker
i have one if you wouldn't mind
terese ma'am
i've heard what the last two presenters
have said you've talked about your
rights this bill specifically says an
employee shall have the right to be
vaccinated against covet 19
and the right to use personal protective
equipment such as a face mask and a face
shield while employed in the workplace
correct
are you aware of any situations where an
employer has refused to allow someone to
be vaccinated or refuse to allow someone
to utilize protective devices
no and i would say you know an employer
do they have dress codes yeah they have
dress codes you know if they're
in a setting where they don't feel the
mask is appropriate um
you know that it's going to alarm i
don't know their preschoolers who are
trying to learn speech
my mind tried to think about who would
ever say that an employee can't wear
their mask and ppe to work i have not
heard of anyone
stepping into that
place and enforcing that on people when
they're when we are in the midst of a
pandemic and we do have a virus that is
making people very sick
i
believe that employers
will
typically want to do what they can to
support their employees especially right
now when
people are desperate for good workers
and i think everyone's been very
you know
fair and and cares about their employees
enough to say if you feel like you need
a face mask to keep yourself safe we're
going to support you in that but yet
they're not supporting the person who
says i feel like i'm harboring a bunch
of bacteria in this warm dark moist
sugary
air that's on this you know my
seven-year-old his mask comes home
stopping wet
and he got sick eight times last year
and developed a nervous tic because of
his mask reminders he's not given the
same liberty to make a choice
but i have not experienced an employer
saying you're not allowed to wear mass
care especially in today's environment
they would be crucified
but i i believe that employers should
not be messing with medical
interventions and i believe right now we
already have that you go to your hr and
you say have a medical condition ada i
need to wear a mask because i have
asthma i'm compromised
i know you don't want us to wear a mask
because you're conservative and you're
way over here and you don't want to hire
someone who's vaccinated i would say
that you know our our constitution i've
really read through some of our labor
laws that person would have a medical
justification to have that accommodation
made for them to be vaccinated to have
their mask i really feel like that's
already in place
all right thank you are there any other
questions
seeing none thank you very much i do not
have any additional pink cards for house
bill
1088 is there anyone else would like to
speak yes please
i've never done this before could you
please bring that up so i can know who
you are please um kendra goodwin i live
in sandown new hampshire
sorry the acoustics here aren't great we
all have masks on could you speak a
little closer to the microphone yeah um
my name is kendra goodwin i'm from
sandown new hampshire
and i've never done this before so it's
like nerve-wracking
but i'm a single mom of three and i
spent the entire summer
with anxiety and worrying about my job
and you know luckily they accepted my
my um religious exemption
but other people weren't as fortunate
and i just wanted to say that
i don't think there should be
discrimination either way i agree you
know with that but if it's there's no
discrimination that way it has to be for
people that don't want it either
i personally have a 13 year old daughter
who is injured from a vaccine
she is up all night every night she's
sweats like seizure movements we have
been to every doctor
imaginable for four years and no one
knows what's wrong with her she was also
diagnosed with reactive arthritis which
is a side effect from vaccines and then
that turned into neurological issues she
can't be go to school she can't have a
normal life
so this is personal to me and that's
when i started
you know there's two sides to everything
and
i think there needs to be open
discussion about these things and where
there's a risk
there should always be a choice whether
that be employers which is just at this
point an extension of the government
because they do whatever you know these
big corporations do whatever the
government tells them to do
and i i
work in the medical field i look at
hearts every day and i've seen
heartbreaking things that aren't
reported
there's a lot of things that aren't
reported my um
my cousin's daughter's teacher was just
diagnosed with gillian beret from the
vaccine
my
i've had patients
i've had patients come to me and they
say you know i've been short of breath
for three months as ever since i had
that vaccine i've never had this problem
before their d-dimers are through the
roof which indicate blood clotting and i
look at hearts and that causes pulmonary
hypertension and these people will die
from heart failure
it's a serious thing and it's something
that we need to have a choice about
and like i said a lot of these are never
reported because they don't they're like
oh it can't be from that the cdc says
you can only have reactions within 48
hours that's not true
that's not true at all and
with any bill coming up and i've never
paid attention to local politics i've
never been involved in any of this in my
life and i am now and
the last two years has opened my eyes to
anything it's just the utter corruption
going on
so um i said this is personal to me
i have a vaccine or daughter and i just
whenever there is any type of risk there
has to be a choice regardless of
what legislation it is and i can tell
you that me and my family are paying
close attention and i don't you know i
voted vote republican down the line and
i will not do that anymore if people
don't stand up for our freedoms
thank you
not bad for the first time
thank you are there any questions
for the speaker
seeing none thank you very much
representative horrigan before you take
off i do need your pink card
i i'd like to now call
ed groves
i'd like to speak on
i'm sorry that's
the next one my apologies
lana
condon
recognized do i have that right
good morning my name is laura condon
and i'm from bedford
and
sorry i was late i didn't get to hear
the introduction on this bill
but i understand that is it a
well-intentioned bill to provide
employees with choice when it comes to
vaccination
but my concern with this bill and i ask
that an amendment be considered
to provide for non-discrimination of
those who choose not to be vaccinated
and not to wear this
personal protective equipment because
this bill simply protects those that do
choose
so i think it would be appropriate to
protect those
who choose not to avail themselves of of
those products or devices thank you very
much
thank you are any questions for the
speaker
seeing none thank you very much i have
no additional pink cards
no additional individuals to speak so
i'll close the hearing
on house bill 1088 and we will start
again
at 11 50 on house bill 1210
thank you very much
so
i'm sorry
sorry andrew
still i apologize so thank you for being
willing to deal with me
is representative lang here still
he stepped out on the phone okay is he
going to present his bill
i don't have a card
some information
for the labor committee
i'd like to let you know the bills that
i plan to exec next thursday at the uh
conclusion of our
um
day's hearings
so i don't know if anyone wants to write
this down or
i will get an email out to everybody but
just so you know
we'll be
executing cacr 14
house bill 53
56 fn
1207 fn
i'm sorry linda
1156 fn
1207 fn
and 1538
and please watch your emails there have
been
i've been notified of a few amendments
i want to make sure everyone has them
prior to the next
one of our labor committee meetings
so you have
them
to ask questions of and be prepared for
during the day prior to exec session
any questions
like i said i will have an email
out with these
but brian wanted to know so brian now
knows
representative lang are you going to
introduce the next bill
give me one of these little punjabis so
i can be prepared
nope
uh
so
okay
oh
um
you
i will begin again in two minutes folks
adam nice to see you
i thought
okay
really nice
so
thank you
ladies and gentlemen i'm going to open
the hearing on house bill 1210
just a few reminders folks
please
don't address another individual's
speaker's comments
and try to keep any
comments like
a boo
or an applause down to a minimum
we are here in the chamber
i'd like to call
representative lang followed by david
duvet representative lang you represent
you're acknowledged to
thank you mr chairman
thank you members of the committee i'll
try to make sure the applause is kept to
a minimum
um
i'm here to introduce house bill 1210
house bill 1210 on its face is a
time warp bill the goal of this bill is
to go back before we politicized codefit
and the way businesses used to handle
things like medical vaccine exemption
requests
prior to covid businesses routinely
handled on a regular basis and dealt
with accommodation requests from
employees
however now we step into a coveted world
and the biggest problem is government
decide to put its thumb on the scale
in these decisions that businesses have
to make
so when it comes to covid we've had
things like the certain general come out
and decide and tell businesses that
they're going to investigate
religious exemptions and whether or not
they're going to be they're being abused
so i want you to think about that for a
minute the idea and concept that either
the federal government
or your business is going to investigate
you to decide whether or not you're
religious enough or spiritual enough to
be entitled to a religious exemption
same goes with medical exemptions you
now have to while you're not asking for
an ada accommodation for a rant or a
stand-up desk or something that the
business would have to do a special
accommodation for you on
you're asking for just under medical
condition that i have i'm not able to
get my vaccine so therefore i want an
exemption except now the business is
requiring that you release your personal
data
your personal medical data to the
business to explain why you're entitled
to this
medical request and then they'll measure
that as well decide whether or not they
think that your medical reason is good
enough
not to get a vaccine and to be entitled
to an exemption
this should be horrific for us to think
about that our businesses and our
government could potentially do this
so this bill looks to go back to prior
to code and go back to the standard we
used to have which is basically an
employee submits an exemption request
that exemption request is granted
the business then enters basically into
negotiations with the employee on what a
reasonable accommodation is
if they can't come to an accommodation
the business can fire the employee and
the employee can sue the business and
and say that they didn't offer me a
reasonable accommodation but that'll be
dealt with in the court system just like
it did prior to coded this is how we
handle things
again we go back to this idea
of
measuring measuring medical entitlement
measuring religious entitlement
do we really want our business to do it
is there's a great article in the bia
magazine talking about how this is a
huge problem for businesses because
we're talking about potential civil
rights violations now imagine a business
not granting religious exemptions
there are religions out there
that say you can't get vaccinated you
shouldn't get vaccinated a lot of this
is based on the concept of stem cell
research and abortion it's under a
foundation of their faith
imagine a business saying we're not
going to allow religious exemptions
where we're going to tighten up really
hard on our religious exemptions and
therefore certain religions basically
can't be employed
again this should be chilling this
should be a chilling idea that would
that we are going to allow businesses
decide what religions are allowed to
work in their environment which ones
aren't
a horrific idea
lastly the one object we're going to
talk about which is the new thing
because we generally medical and
religious exemptions were always granted
without without an issue it's only since
coveted and the federal government
decided to step on federal contractors
and step into the osha law and step into
the labor laws and create mandates which
have since been overturned as mandates
and step and threaten people's
livelihood having a job
threaten businesses ability to keep
federal contracts this is why this bill
is in front of you as i got from a
manufacturer that called me from the
lakes region who was extremely concerned
about the federal contractor
requirements that he was going to lose
10 percent of his workforce and he was
concerned about how he was going to be
able to meet the federal mandate
requiring it
and this is a simple answer
so we're going to talk just real quick
about the new edition that's in there
and that's conscientious objector which
is on sorry i'm trying to find my phone
excited that's some comments i want to
read so conscientious objector
so as we talk about individual rights i
go to the new hampshire constitution
because it's one of my favorite
documents to read read about
so you're going to hear about three
different articles within our part one
new hampshire constitution
article three which is everyone likes to
cite and say this is why we should have
mandates article three says when men
enter into a state of society they
surrender up some of their natural
rights to that society in order to
ensure the protection of others and
without such equivalent the surrender is
void so that basically says
in order to be in a polite society we
have to give up some of our rights
however the constitution goes on
an article number four of the new
hampshire constitution
rights of conscience unalienable
among the natural rights
some are in their very nature
unalienable because no equivalent can be
given or received for them
of this right kind of rights is the
right of i'm sorry of this kind are the
rights of conscience
so i had to go look up what is
unalienable mean
so unalienable according to
us history.org which does a site on on
the u.s constitution's use of the word
unadill says
unalienable rights
that are mentioned in the declaration of
independence
could just have been the word enabled
which means the same thing inaudible or
unailer refers to that which cannot be
given
or taken away
it cannot take away the right of
conscience
so as people have
and i use the phrase organic lifestyle
right they have a they have a
philosophical belief in their life where
and my ex-wife is one of them who
believes that
they eat organic food they try to reduce
the amount of processed foods they eat
they don't take
they try all organic or health
related activities before they take a
prescription so again i'm one of these
people as well i i have a family history
of heart disease i went to my
cardiologist at 45 years old i did my
little treadmill test
and a doctor said well you don't have
any heart disease but i want you to take
the snap drug on a regular basis because
of your history my response was i don't
want to take a medication for the rest
of my life i want the chance to
do this naturally so what's the response
you have to do
i have to eat healthier and i have to
exercise so i eat healthy and i've
exercised
clean bill of health and my cardiologist
without the need to take
a drug for the rest of my life just as a
precautionary
so to me that's a consider the right of
conscious i didn't i wasn't forced that
drug but it was my choice my my personal
choice not to inject not to ingest a
chemical substance that would be
probably good for my health but i had
alternatives to do
so in this case i believe this is the
same exact thing we should not be
forcing people to do a mandate of
vaccination and especially when we talk
about and it's always going to be about
coping for a while but we talk about the
covid vaccine we know that it's not a
curative vaccine i think everybody
agrees with that point at this point
it's not curative it is mitigating and i
agree with that but it's not curative it
doesn't solve the problem it just
lessens the problem and while i think
that that's a good thing there are also
other ways that could be handled without
impinging on somebody's right of
conscience their religious beliefs or
their medical data
so
again i look at this bill and i say to
you that
this bill will help businesses
streamline processes it'll reduce
potential lawsuits because there's an
obligation now that they meet they
accept the uh
religious exemption and negotiate just
the idea of a reasonable accommodation
and then lastly we have this issue of
the federal government these
federal contractors
so with this bill
manufacturing lakes region could
implement a mandatory
vaccination process as required by the
federal government for for his federal
contracts
but he can also turn around and follow
state law and accept
the exemption of his employees and be
consistent with both laws
and it allows that employer to be able
to manage his company do what he needs
to do for his employees and his job
without
losing workforce
so i know there's probably a lot of
questions i know there probably a lot of
people want to speak again i think this
is a common sense bill i think it
respects individual rights it respects
the business rights um and i think we
should i hope you recommend otp for this
bill happy to take any questions
thank you representative
by sherman seaworth followed by
representative proud
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative for introducing
this bill
i heard some things you said in your
testimony that i want to kind of square
with the language of the bill you
mentioned a couple times
a process of reasonable accommodation
and mentioned that so once an exemption
is granted it's still up to the employer
and the employee to find reasonable
accommodation and if that can't be
obtained
the employer retains the right to
dismiss the employee
because of that
in the bill language it simply says
that the employer shall grant such
exemption so i'm kind of wondering at
what where in the process is the
employer protected
that if they can't
absolutely so
to answer your question or i think i can
answer your question that actually can
be found over in federal statutes that
talk about business mandates and it
talks about accommodations this came out
of um
at a supreme court case
that says that businesses
have to if they have a mandate they have
to do accommodations they have to accept
exemptions and then those
but they can also set reasonable
accommodations was the language that's
used in the federal law
so i didn't want to rewrite federal code
representative proud followed by
representative abalone
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative line for taking my
question
um
do you think that in addition to
i can't hear you
sorry do you think that in addition to
the direct mandates that are coming down
from the federal government that
businesses are concerned that
whether they mandate on their own will
be
looked on favorably or disfavorably in
any discretionary interaction with the
federal government or with other
officials and they're concerned
that if they don't require all their
employees be vaccinated or be strict
about religious exemptions they'll be
disfavored in their interactions with
the federal government
so you know this is a hypothetical guess
right so again as a i would argue yes
you're right you know we saw that osha
right tried to force down 100-plus
mandate right and that was what they
wanted and it wasn't until the supreme
court stepped in that that was stymied
from them
um so do i think that if a businesses
has
a mandate will they be viewed more
favorably by the federal government sure
i think i think that that's just the
nature of unfortunately politics right
now
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
representative lang
why did you choose section 141c instead
of 275 which is most
employee or employer protections located
at 275.
so the 141c language are communicable
diseases statutes and that's why i put
it in there because this is relevant
directly to where we have all of our
vaccination statutes it's where we have
all of our exemption statutes for
students in school
and all of our quarantining statutes are
in there so i felt that having it under
the
the immunization statute
was the best place to do it
follow up
thank you mr chairman um would you be
opposed to having it
started under 275 colon three
which uh procuring employment and
imposition of conditions sorry
representative examination
representative i can't even hear you
could you speak closely to mike
and you have to be directly in front of
it
275 colon 3 has medical examination and
records furnishes furnished for
conditions of employment
would you be opposed if this was moved
to there
if you think you have a better section
that's chapter of law do you want to
amend it to put it into that chapter of
law i'm completely fine with that
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you i'm sorry i didn't introduce myself
i'm representative tim lang from belknap
county for
third term state representative and
chairman of the fish and game committee
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative flang um
i got to preface my my question to you
um
i don't think there's probably anybody
in this room who's is
more concerned about the conscience
conscientious objector exemption than
myself
i work for 120 000 employee
company and we were
under the federal mandate and
my job after 37 years was threatened
with termination last november if i did
not get vaccinated or
asked for an exemption which i couldn't
under the
exemptions so i and i was only one one
of four percent of our entire company
that said no to everything
under threat determination
but having said that
in this committee
for the years that i've been here
we do not like to get in between
the
employer and the employee relationship
we avoid that we don't see it as
bureaucrat or politicians purview to
get involved in
so how do i as much as i love what
you're trying to do how do i reconcile
the private business
employee relationship
and your bill
if copenhagen had happened i wouldn't
file this bill right so this bill is
about the influence of federal
government is exacting on businesses to
make it so that businesses
basically no longer have a choice
whether or not they want to instead of
it being their business decision it's
the federal government specific uh
decision and so the goal of this is
in those situations where the employer
is basically stuck between the the
federal government up top telling you're
going to do this as part of a labor law
how can the state mitigate and help that
business and so i look at this bill as a
mitigation bill for businesses that
we're trying to help them by saying that
we understand that there's a workforce
issue and we're going to try and give
you an out if you want to use it you're
welcome to use it and and this is what
this is how how you can use it so you
can meet that federal requirement and
you can also meet the state requirement
and and keep your workforce in place i
would rather not
represent turcotte i'm just like you i
don't want to impose any more rules and
regulations on business than i
absolutely have to the problem is that
businesses are now and sorry dave
businesses are starting to become the
shell of the federal government they're
forcing down federal government
regulations onto their employees and
taking away employee choice
okay to be clear
is what you're attempting to do with
this strictly from mandates sent down
from the federal government alone that
would be question one the second
question is
let's forget about covet let's just say
there's something else i'm an employer
and i tell my employees i want you to do
x
forget about vaccines
i
still see i don't understand how this is
not
bureaucrats and politicians getting in
between the middle of an employer and
again
i'm on the tip of the spear on this one
so i understand it but i just having
trouble still reconciling that
so i guess if you if you were to how can
i word this politely
if i agree with you i i again i would i
would not have filed this bill if we
didn't have some of the problems we're
having so i chair the hb 220 committee
on medical interventions
and i heard two and a half days of
testimony public testimony never mind
the two days of testimony of agencies
and businesses but two and a half days
of public testimony of time after time
again where businesses stepped on
citizens either religious rights or they
stepped on the conscientious objector
rights
so and in almost every single case the
reason the business stepped on it was
because there was a push down from above
and it was a problem
and so
given the given the weight of or given
the decision am i going to protect the
business right or am i going to protect
an individual right i'm going to fall
for the individual every single time
right i'm going to protect the
individuals right and not have business
force stuff down their throat um so if
there's a case of in our constitution
it's clear the conscience the right of
conscience is extremely laid out it's
it's called out separately as an
inalienable right and i recognize that
some people believe the constitution is
between the government and its citizen
versus business and a citizen i get that
but in this case where i think that it's
a legitimate we're not asking them to
um
blanket granted we're just saying you
have to grant it and then work your
accommodations the way we did before we
politicized covet again this is
what a lot of people
need to understand is that
before kobe this was a routine event in
a business and it rarely raised any
concerns
um
and now because of the politicization
we've done of public health and
politicization being done of covid
now it's an issue and now people are
we're we're pitting the government
against business and business against
the individual and i don't want to see
that
follow-up problem
i'm good mr chairman thank you very much
thank you representative representative
sullivan you recognize
your question
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony and taking my question
representative lang
in your testimony
you uh referenced
the need
for individuals to sometimes give up
some of their rights
for the sake of uh the society
um and you also referenced the
conscientious uh rights the inalienable
rights
um
would you agree that the
uh framers of the constitution
perhaps thought that there needed to be
a balance between the two that
you had to figure out
what
society really needs in order to figure
out whether or not rights need to be
relinquished
thank you for your question
representative sullivan and i guess to
answer that question i just find it
i find it uh what's the word i want to
use extremely important to say that the
new hampshire framers of the
constitution specifically called out the
right of conscience
over
um
the the third section which says you
have to give some up and he specifically
called the right of conscience
unalienable meaning that which would not
be given or taken away
if they had meant not to make it to make
the right of conscience as a as one of
those rights that you can give up in
society
uh in order to participate in a society
they wouldn't erode section four they
wouldn't have been needed they would
have just left section three all by
itself as a standalone saying sometimes
you have to give up rights to be in
society but then they went on and
specifically called out the right of
conscience and specifically said it was
unalienable cannot be given or taken
away i think that speaks volumes to the
intent of what they meant
follow up
thank you
the
framers of the constitution did not
however
determine that the right
of an employer to require a vaccine
was an inalienable right
this bill makes it ineligible but
not the constitution
so i guess i disagree it would not be
illegal for an employer to put a mandate
on right this bill does not make it
illegal for an employer to set a mandate
it just makes the employer also be
responsible to the individual rights
including the right of conscience of its
workforce
representative mandeville you're
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative lang for appearing here
with respect to
this bill if this bill were to pass and
let's say a
a an employee
who let's say was working a cash
register
applied for this the exemption
and
it would be granted per the terms of the
bill
and the employer
said well my customers or other people
working here are concerned and so that's
fine but you're going to have to work in
the back
rather than on the register
would would that implicate anything in
your bill would that create a violation
or a right in the employee
or
would it involve what is intended to be
covered by this bill
thank you for your question actually
falls in line with a federal court case
so it was a federal court case in in uh
that was about uh accommodations what is
the reasonable accommodations or not
this in this particular case it was
about healthcare and it was a nurse and
the nurse was a scheduling nurse who did
who just called patients to schedule
operations schedule things
the
hospital put a mandate in
the nurse asked for an exemption
they outright denied her
she sued saying that they didn't do a
reasonable accommodation for me and she
won
and the reason she won is because
that job function had no bearing on
patients there was no there was no
threat to patients there was no threat
to the job force
so i i use it again in a health care
setting which is probably the easiest
one to understand when it talks to
reasonable accommodations is i use an
ecology board cancer ward right it is
completely reasonable to say that people
in a cancer ward must be vaccinated
because cancer patients have a have a
compromised immune system we know that
and it's a it's a life-threatening
situation if they get sick
so and i know laura's probably staring
at daggers at me right now but but i
think it's a reasonable reasonable to
say that a nurse in a cancer ward must
be vaccinated
and if they didn't want to be vaccinated
and filed for an exemption it's
completely okay to say to that nurse
you can't work in a college award
because of the threat to the patient but
you can still be a nurse and you'll work
over in podiatry
right where the threat to the patient is
significantly less that is a reasonable
accommodation i believe and i think that
would have won but the outright saying
you can't be a nurse is not is not a
reasonable accommodation so
um i i think that sort of answers your
question that there are reasonable
accommodations employer can make and
whether it's moving an employee
whether it's
whatever other i can't think of whatever
other things they might do but what if
they want to move an employee to a
non-facing uh you know customer facing
position again as long as you don't
impact their wages which is not a
reasonable accommodation cut their cut
their salary give them a lesser position
then yeah that's going to be deemed a
reasonable accommodation
are there any additional questions for
representative lang
thank you mr speaker
thank you representative
am i incorrect in thinking that people
who have
cancer or
other immune suppression problems may
also have
feed problems and need to see a
podiatrist and how would they know
that the person who would be interacting
with them was not vaccinated and thus
not protecting them to the degree that
they could
sure great and i i guess what i would
say is that the answer is right on your
face
so if i had cancer and i was concerned
about going someplace i take my own
precautions
to deal with my own risks right if i'm
going to go to the podiatrist and i wear
a mask if that if i'm concerned i have
cancer and i think that's going to be an
issue i can take my health and my
responsibility among
among myself without impacting another
person right i can wear a mask i can
wear i can get the n95 mask i can pay
extra to go get the
fitted masks and then i'm protected from
that right and i don't have to impose
upon you
because of yours because of your
sickness to uh or because i'm sick i
don't have to impose upon you i can take
care of that responsibility on my own
i'm not sure if that answers your
question but i think it goes both
directions
all right thank you very much for your
testimony thank you sir we are running a
little late but there's room in our
schedule so
house bill 1351 which is scheduled for
11 45 will be as soon as we get done
with the folks here and then we have
time in our lunch break if we um go over
like you now call david duvet followed
by kate frey
mr duvet thank you mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
dave juven senior vice president for
public policy with the business and
industry association
i initially arrived here this morning
with the intention to oppose this bill
our concern
was that it places employers that under
that are under federal mandates meaning
those employers that receive medicaid
funding or those employers that have
federal
can you hear me okay
those employees that are employers that
have federal contracts are under a
vaccine mandate that they're expected to
adhere to i don't think that makes them
shills i think that employers around the
country have for many years been
obligated to follow regulations they
come down from the federal government
and i felt like this bill was getting in
the way
i had a very
cordial
conversation with representative lang
the sponsor before the hearing
and he explained what he was trying to
do
i i have to tell the committee i'm not
entirely convinced that that is what it
will do but it was plausible enough to
ask the if he would accept an invitation
to come to the bia to talk to our
federal labor attorneys who are experts
on this issue
relating to medical exemptions
religious exemptions
and
that third area conscientious objection
objectors which is my
real concern because the federal mandate
doesn't speak to that
so there's a courtesy to him i told him
that we would remain neutral on this
bill until we had a chance to have that
conversation together and so that's
where we're at
representative lang has been kind enough
we'll be getting together over the next
week to two weeks to have that
conversation at that point i may be
reaching out to the community with with
further information
mr chair i'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you any questions representative
seaworth followed by sullivan
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
duvet for testifying today i'm wondering
if um
as you heard from my previous question
i'm interested in this
reasonable accommodation and exactly how
that would imply to
employers i'm wondering if you had
already discussed that issue and if not
i would encourage that as
you continue to meet on it you help us
understand that area yeah i thought your
observation about
whether the bill could be clarified to
to understand that it is calling for a
reasonable accommodation it is just not
the
employer's obligation to
to
accede to the request was a good one
employers are are very well versed
in dealing with reasonable
accommodations and a lot of other areas
it is not uncommon at all
so i guess my overall concern about that
is less than perhaps
yours might be but i think it is an area
that's worth at least exploring
my major concern was
that those employers who are under the
federal mandate
could be in a very tough position if
this law
is prohibiting them from from
complying with the federal mandate i
know representative lang
believes that it it doesn't and that
makes it good for employers
i just need a little more confirmation
on that
representative sullivan
thank you mr chair um i'd like to second
uh representative seaworth's um concern
because i don't i'm not confident that
that
reasonable accommodation would be
required under this bill
and would be comforted in knowing
whether it would or would not
um and i also trust that you will be
emailing the
committee with your conclusions after
the meeting with representative lang and
your attorneys that's exactly my
intention thank you thank you any
further questions for mr gervais
see none thank you very much
like to now call kate frey followed by
steven hearn
good morning members of the committee
i'm shorter than dave dj
um new futures um appreciates the
opportunity to be here to testify and
offer this opposition to house bill 1210
um my name is kate bryan the vice
president of advocacy at new futures uh
we're a non-partisan nonprofit
organization that advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all new hampshire residents
in this world we work extensively with
policymakers healthcare providers and
communities to improve the overall
public health in the granite state
we support public health policies that
decrease illness and diseases including
vaccines and programs to ensure
equitable and broad distribution of
vaccine and other evidence-based
treatments
house bill 1210 directs private employer
post-secondary institutions or clinical
sites for educational programs to accept
requests for employees or students for
exemptions for vaccine mandates
vaccinations protect individuals and the
community from the risk of severe
illness and have essentially eradicated
some deadly diseases
they also prevent those who can't get
vaccinated including infants or people
with weakened immune systems
colleges and university campuses in
particular at a higher risk for
outbreaks of other communicable diseases
due to students attending classes or
living in close quarters increasing
geographical
diverse student population and a higher
prevalence of certain diseases this is
why most colleges and universities
require hepatitis b
meningitis vaccines and other
routine childhood vaccinations
and hundreds of these institutions are
also requiring cova 19 vaccines
hb 1210 um proposes to request a
conscientious exemption for all vaccine
mandates
if passed this amendment would tie the
hands of these entities
and limit their ability to enforce
public health policies
medical exemptions one necessary
component of vaccine policies however an
objection based on conscientious or
philosophical reasons essentially
allowing an easy opt-out to anyone would
reverse the progress new hampshire has
made in defeating this pandemic and
other previously eradicated diseases
according to the infection disease
society of america studies demonstrate
that it's that the easier it is to
receive an exemption the higher the rate
of exemptions in particular states as
the number of extensions increase the
risk of the vaccine preventable disease
also increases therefore states should
make the effort to minimize the number
of
people exempted from immunization
mandates
exemptions increase health costs by the
need to investigate and control
avoidable outbreaks costs that are paid
for by taxpayers and many of whom who
are vaccinated
state government should not provide a
prevent an entity for making choices
based on public health and safety
concerns especially during a public
health pandemic
for those reasons new future strongly
urges the community to vote against to
have bill 12
thank you for your testimony any
questions for the presenter
saint john thank you very much for your
testimony
stephen o'hearn followed by debbie sire
mr chairman
did i get that grug a-h
i'm sorry representative
mr chairman
would it be okay if i were to ask the
prime uh could i ask the prime sponsor a
question
you want to ask the prime sponsor a
question yes please
is representative lying still here okay
mr herm would you mind holding
representative
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative
my question
is
why did you include a clinical sites on
line four in the first part of your bill
thank you you talk about the it includes
institutions that provide clinical sites
or educational
yes
thank you for that question so that was
a very specific um ask that i got i i
worked with i got a lot of phone calls
after house bill 220
was put into law and our university
systems are are
obligated to house bill 220 which says
that government cannot mandate
vaccinations
the problem we got was our nursing
programs and our college systems was our
nursing programs do clinical testing at
hospitals they do clinical surveys
walkthroughs and that kind of thing
so i got a phone call from a bunch of
people
saying i have a problem i can't get my
clinicals done as a nurse a nursing
student because the hospital is
requiring and therefore the university
is now saying i have to have my
vaccination
and so the idea behind that inclusion
was just that was that i i tried to work
with concord hospital
to work out to work out a problem for
nhgi specifically was the first one i
went to
where the nurses needed to do clinical
site training at the hospital but were
didn't want to get vaccinated and the
state couldn't require them to be
vaccinated but they couldn't pass their
class unless they had the clinical so
they were kind of in this catch-22 phase
so the idea behind this was that things
like concord hospital or any clinical
care could be a nursing home or
something else that may have a vaccine
mandate
would again if a student asked to be
exempt from the from the mandate would
be exempted from it but the hospital
could require accommodations and it may
be that again you can't tour the
oncology board right you're going to go
over to podiatry you're going to go over
to a different board sorry i don't keep
meaning to pick up podiatry but um
but again you know the idea was to allow
our nursing students we're in a nursing
crisis to be able to complete their
training get certified as a nurse and
then deal with those once they become an
employer they can deal with an employee
basis what hospital they choose to work
at what clinical setting they choose to
work out but we need to be able to allow
our student nurses the ability to
complete their degree programs
and that was why that was specifically
inserted again with the idea concord
hospital originally loved the idea that
ghosted me refused to return my phone
call and so i i was going along the idea
of doing accommodations and the
president of the hospital was responsive
to that he went to doctor's chief
medical officer and then i never had
another phone call i couldn't get a
return text message nothing so i
included that in my statement and say
that hospitals must also allow for
reasonable accommodation for nursing
students so they can complete their
degree program
all right thank you
mr hearn i
apologize to speak new hampshire h
hospital association i assume yes that's
right good morning mr chairman members
of the committee my name is steve anand
i'm the president of hampshire hospital
association and i'm here representing
all of our state's hospitals
the nhh is opposed to house bill 1210
this legislation would prevent private
employers from requiring vaccines of
their employees as a condition of
employment without offering exemptions
for medical religious or conscientious
objection
hb 1210 would also as we just heard
prevent hospitals that provide clinical
rotations for training of a wide variety
of clinicians from requiring that those
students adhere to the evidence-based
policies and protocols that they have
established for the health and safety of
their patients workforce and students
who are training there hb 1210 would
essentially render moot any requirements
that an employer has determined are in
the best interest of those they serve by
simply saying no to the vaccine
requirement on the grounds of a
conscientious objection declaration the
new hampshire hospital association its
member hospitals announced in august of
last year a consensus statement in
support of requiring our healthcare
workforce to be vaccinated against cova
19 in order to protect the health and
safety of our patients our staff and our
communities hospitals have announced
their own individual policies and have
been implementing them without with
robust education for their staff about
the important benefits of the vaccine in
doing so the hospitals have sought to be
flexible and have complied with all
relevant state and federal guidelines
including offering medical and religious
exemptions
hospitals in the tens of thousands of
dedicated healthcare workers who come to
work in them every day have been on the
front lines of the pandemic for almost
two years
the decision to require their employees
to be vaccinated against coba 19 as i
said was done to ensure the health and
safety of their patients their workforce
in their communities they have seen
firsthand the devastation that cova 19
can have on their patients especially
those who are unvaccinated while we have
seen more breakthrough cases impacting
those who have been vaccinated or
hospitalized those on the front lines
tell us over and over the patients who
are the most severely ill intubated and
in the intensive care unit are those
that are unvaccinated
hospitals have an inherent
responsibility to protect the health and
safety of their patients who by their
very nature are very ill and the coba 19
vaccine is the most effective way we can
do that the vaccines approved for use in
the united states are safe and highly
effective in preventing infection
serious illness hospitalization and
death
studies have shown that unvaccinated
individuals are at a fivefold higher
risk of infection from coba 19 and
10-fold higher risk of dying from hope
from hospitalization from coven-19 and
11-fold risk of dying from coca-19
requiring vaccinations of healthcare
workers from communicable diseases is
not new for hospitals in new hampshire
hospitals are required vaccination
against several communicable and deadly
diseases such as mumps measles rubella
chickenpox diphtheria diseases pertussis
influenza as a condition of employment
but the same type of medical and
religious exemptions allowed for covet
19 vaccines we believe this is
absolutely the right thing to do for the
health and safety of our patients our
staff and the citizens of new hampshire
the vast majority of hospital staff have
been vaccinated against coca-19 or
received exemptions and work and we've
heard from many healthcare workers who
support the vaccine requirements to
protect their health and that of their
patients again new hampshire hospital
association as opposed to house bill
1210 and we urge the committee to find
an expedient to legislate i thank you
for the opportunity to share our views
and i'd be happy to respond to any
questions that you might have
thank you for your testimony questions
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
i'm assuming that the hospital
association or the individual hospitals
keep numbers on the number of employees
percentage that are vaccinated and such
and
if you do so
would you also be able to provide
some numbers that would say what
percentage of those previously
vaccinated
employees ended up becoming infected
with colgan 19. i don't have that
information but what i can share is as
hospitals have implemented their
policies over the past several months
some are just going into effect over the
next several days
we have been trying to understand what
the impact has been on their workforce
and as we understand as of right now
fewer than one percent of
the workforce and health hospital health
care workforce has been separated for
failure to comply with those requirement
policies so it's a very small number of
people who have been impacted we don't
want to lose anyone as you know we have
a workforce shortage hospitals are
stressed um incredibly challenged at
this time dealing with the current surge
in coba 19 and we need every employee
but we also need those employees to be
safe
to be certain that we're providing the
highest quality safest care for our
patients
follow-up
thank you mr chairman thanks again um
that was a very nice answer
unfortunately you didn't answer my
question
maybe the question i don't i don't have
that data to ship
maybe my new question would be could you
get us the data on what percentage of
those that you required vaccinations on
ended up at some point or another
becoming infected with covid
we'll certainly look at that i don't
know that i'll be able to answer that
question i will share
in fact the
wall street journal today had an article
sharing cdc data that demonstrated the
increase in the number of
breakthrough infections that we were
seeing currently versus during the delta
surge as for both those who are
vaccinated as well as those who are
unvaccinated i mean we have seen more
breakthrough cases
here in new hampshire as we have across
the country
any additional questions
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question uh do
hospitals currently
allow for medical or religious
exemptions they do they do okay thank
you
so you know additional hands thank you
very much for your testimony
debbie sear followed by ed groves
good morning
thank you for the opportunity to speak
regarding hb 1210
relative to exemptions from vaccine
mandates i'm debbie scary i'm the
president of new hampshire college and
university council
and for those of you who perhaps aren't
familiar with our the association it's a
non-profit consortium of both the public
and private institutions of higher
education in our state
and these institutions are recognized
and highly regarded for their
outstanding teaching research and
community service activities they serve
as major centers of activity that are
vital to the economic development of the
community
and the state
i speak today in opposition to house
bill 1210 as it would eliminate the
colleges and universities ability to
follow the current guidelines
established by the american college
health association which include
vaccinations like meningitis mmr etc
these guidelines have been in place long
before
kovid was part of our lives and they
provide our campuses with standards
based on established public health
principles
our colleges have successful processes
in place based on these standards
that allow students to request
exemptions for vaccines for documented
medical reasons or religious beliefs our
universities have a long and really
positive history of managing exemptions
from vaccines hb 1210 would disrespect
sorry
disrupt the successful practice that is
currently in place
that could jeopardize the health
and well-being of our campus and
communities thank you for your time
today and i'd be very happy to try and
answer any questions you might have
are there any questions for the
presenter
cena thank you very much for your
testimony
ed graves followed by kathy horgan
thank you very much my name is ed groves
jr uh that's my father ed grove senior
back there he's 85 years old
um the reason i'm pushing for this
exemption is because
everywhere you look turn read mainstream
media even our own new hampshire.gov
websites tell us how safe this vaccine
is
it's not safe
my dad got the vaccine in august
again he's 85 years old
5 30 at night
went home woke up the next morning 10
a.m he's in his kitchen
goes unconscious doesn't remember
blacking out doesn't remember anything
thankfully his girlfriend came
downstairs found him called
in the er 911 elliot
doctor
does all the tests sends him home a day
later
coincidence maybe
maybe not
you can't
force people to get something that's not
safe whether it's one or twenty thousand
like bears says people are dying from
this vaccine
kids
are are getting blood clots
boys
getting myocardiasis carditis
this is live free or die state you guys
have a chance to be pioneers here i mean
this is one bill of the many that i'm in
support of
ivor ivermectic please i know i'm not
supposed to talk about bill 1022 but
that's
a successful drug
i used it
i had covert for two days felt better
afterwards again i'm sorry i'm nervous
right now i don't really speak in front
of
legislative bodies but
there are so many people that want to be
here that are working right now
that are part of our group here
you guys
you have a chance to to make a statement
to the rest of the country okay
um something was brought up about
federal monies
everybody every state with sanctuary
cities breaks federal rule every day
i don't know what the feds are doing
about that
not much again i'm getting off off
there's so much i want to say it's all
written down and i'm not reading from it
and let me finally say this
my ideology is probably different than
some of yours
we're all individuals
if i were your boss all 20 of you
and friday rolls around for your
paychecks and i call you all in my
office and i say hey how many of you
been vaccinating half of you raise your
hands and i say to you well i don't
think like you do so you no longer have
a job because you're vaccinated i know
that sounds kind of weird but
that's enough thank you
thank you mr gross
any questions for the presenter or the
speaker
seeing none
thank you
kate horgan followed by laura condon
thank you members of the labor committee
my name is kate organ i serve as the
executive director of the new hampshire
association of counties which represents
all of your elected and appointed
officials in county government
specifically today i'm speaking on
behalf of the county nursing homes who
are extremely concerned about this bill
and have asked the association to oppose
this bill
right now the only exemptions that the
cms regulations allow for
are religious and medical there is no
conscientious exemption and we feel that
would set state policy and federal
policy
against each other putting us in the
position of having to choose which
policy we're going to follow
uh that could result if we chose to
follow state policy the feds taking away
our medicaid money which as you know the
counties are responsible for paying the
non-federal share of long-term care in
this state if the rest of that money
goes away
and you're probably looking over 100
million dollars where are those funds
going to come from because the counties
are protected by a cap
that means the state would have to come
up with those money so we are very
concerned about this bill we are having
to work with representative lang if you
would like to
make the language so that it fits with
something that our nursing home
administrators are comfortable with and
with that chairman i will conclude my
testimony i'm happy to take any
questions that the committee has
thank you are there any questions
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman good to see you
again thank you for coming and your
testimony
one question and
in my current situation i i've run into
the same
issue that i keep going through in my
head and that is
you have a medical exemption
you have a religious exemption
i will be working
with individuals who have those
exemptions so they do not have a vaccine
can you
tell me what the difference is between
an unvaccinated individual with a
medical
exemption an unvaccinated individual
with a religious exemption and
somebody with a conscientious objection
can you tell me the difference thank you
for the question representative i think
that's a question for the federal
government and i'm prepared to answer at
this point
abilani
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question um you're here
against this bill has the association
the counties reached out to the federal
delegation
to make sure
to expand the exemptions for county
employees uh thank you for the question
representative yes we speak probably
every other week with the federal
delegation staff about how
this exemption is going to impact county
government
follow up
not the
conscientious objector but for the
medical and
other
yes sir being enforced through cms
yes we speak to them regularly about the
cms mandate
thank you
representative mandeville
thank you mr chairman thank you for
testifying we've had some testimony
already that an increase in opportunity
for exemptions
increases the number that are sought
and i also understand that the nursing
homes have a great concern about
availability of employees in this
staffing challenge time
is your association concerned
that
the increase in exemptions sought and
granted
would
threaten the
staffing issue by
deterring
new employees or driving existing
employees away by virtue of the
increased risk
thank you for the question
representative so i will tell you that
rockingham and merrimack county nursing
homes both did institute a mandate
before the cms guidelines came into
effect and our experience was that we
probably lost 10 or less employees as a
result of that policy change over those
count over those two counties that were
unable to be accommodated with the
religious or the medical exemption
well thank you for that mike my question
though also if unless i misunderstood
your answer was about those who would be
less inclined to work there because of
the fear
of for additional exposure to
covet or other disease from unvaccinated
persons
thank you for the question
representative i will say that we had a
workforce shortage before koben
copenhagen's made it worse
thank you
representative followed by seaworth
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question
um
you mentioned
a moment ago
that
to not follow the federal guidelines
would result in possibly federal money
not being expended
so would i take that and correct me if
i'm wrong in this assumption
what i take that to mean is is if you
don't do what the government tells you
to do
which could lead you to being injured or
dying they will take more money away
from you to make sure that people really
are injured and dying is that what
you're basically saying here uh thank
you for the question representative i
think that is also a question for the
federal government to answer and not
make we just enforce the policies
could i get the number
yes paul could i get the number that i
could call on that i would be happy to
connect you with someone who could get
you in touch with cms but i can't
guarantee an answer
yeah thank you
seaworth
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony i want to clarify
something i think i heard you say in
answering another question
you had talked about the small number of
employees at two counties
that had instituted
the mandates early
and i believe you said that in some or
all of those cases they did
apply for either a medical or religious
exemption
and yet this ability inability to
provide reasonable accommodation still
resulted in their dismissal thank you
for the question representative um i
don't know the answer to that um i don't
know whether or not specific employees
applied for an exemption and were denied
that is just information i do not have
but if that was the result
representative proud
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so you've said that you are concerned
about losing funding if you do not
follow this new cms rule
and that makes me think back to
almost a decade ago when
the federal obamacare law was passed and
there was a requirement to expand
medicaid and that went up in the courts
and it was decided that
the federal government couldn't require
or set down new rules on state
governments
and that there that set up the whole
structure of expanded non-expanded
states and states could continue to
follow the old rules without threat of
loss of funding i believe the court
doesn't know that was national
federation of independent businesses via
sibulous in 2012
is there a reason that you see the
situation now as different from that
that the county governments couldn't
continue to follow the old rules and
reject
this new change that cm is putting down
and still retain the funding they had
before that
thank you representative for the
question i can't speak to the obamacare
piece that's not something i'm familiar
with
but um i will say that the supreme court
just did uphold the cms mandate in
federal court
requiring us to
have a vaccine policy with just the
religious and medical exemptions
thank you
see no additional questions thank you
very much
folks as i know some of the members
we are going to continue through here
and i do have a number of
more pink cards if you need to step out
and grab something to eat please feel
free to do so i just don't want everyone
to go at once um
i'm sorry that but i know some of you i
don't want anyone to pass out on me here
so if you need to get something to eat
or drink feel free
laura condon followed by sean thomas
condon you're recognized
good afternoon
my name is laura condon i'm from bedford
and i'm a volunteer with the national
vaccine information center we are a
non-profit organization
that serves as an educational
my microphone is dynamic i as an
educational resource and advocacy
organization
and as such we have a long-standing
tradition of never supporting any
vaccine mandates anywheres
and so if i were to wear that hat today
i would be opposing this bill
but i'm taking off that hat and i'm
putting on my hat as an individual
because i like dave
juve
spoke to representative tim lang earlier
today
and indeed this is very much a
compromise bill recognizing both sides
of the issue
and in today's environment we need
compromise more than ever in our
communities and our state and our
federal government
and we would be smart to adopt this bill
this bill will resolve staffing issues
it provides appropriate medical
religious and personal privacy
businesses are not in a position
to make determinations on personal
matters
that are medical or religious or indeed
deeply personal
and this bill would relieve them of that
burden
and that responsibility
accepting exemptions
exemptions
will allow businesses to maintain a
hundred percent compliance with vaccine
mandates because those mandates measure
who is gotten the shots or
is in compliance with an exemption
policy and if you can answer yes to both
of those then you're 100 in compliance
and so this would provide just that
wonderful compromise there
um i also would like to mention that
exemptions don't change vaccine
decisions
there's no one that i know of that
knowing that they could get an exemption
and they wanted a vaccine or all the
sudden gonna say you know what i don't
want that vaccine anymore
and there's no one who says i don't want
that vaccine that is all of a sudden is
going to get a vaccine voluntarily
so this really is a reasonable
compromise
one other thing i just want to add to
the conversation here
that i'm surprised that there are any
businesses that would unilaterally
impose vaccine mandates
while there are some businesses that are
having mandates imposed by them by
federal law or other requirements and a
business that independently imposes
vaccine mandates on their employees
needs to be aware that they are not
shielded from immunity for liability for
any harm that happens from those
vaccines and we know from the viirs
reports that hundreds of thousands of
people have been injured and
hospitalized by these vaccines and over
22 000 deaths have been reported
they are not employers are not protected
under the 1986 national childhood
vaccine injury act because they are not
vaccine providers and they are not
protected under the prep act because
their next vaccine providers so i'm
really quite surprised that
any
um independent
any businesses private businesses or
schools would
independently impose these vaccine
mandates so in the end
i do support this bill i think it is a
tremendous compromise
for
all of us that will help with staffing
problems thank you
thank you for your testimony there any
questions of the presenter
thank you very much i'll call on sean
thomas new hampshire nurse association
followed by gary york speaking on behalf
of mankind
thank you mr chair members of the
committee my name is sean thomas with
the mers and praise hall we represent
the new hampshire nurses association
thank you for this opportunity and time
to testify i did provide written
or hard copies of a written statement
prepared by the association which was
also submitted electronically but didn't
want to provide hard copies as well i
won't read it
but instead try to quickly summarize it
i know you're behind schedule
the new hampshire nurses association is
opposed to hb 1210
the intent of hb1210
is to avoid any vaccine mandate
including those imposed by a private
employer
hb 1210 itself however seems to
seems to look like a mandate a mandate
that tells businesses you can't decide
what's in your own best interest
including the health and safety of
employees or in the case of health care
patients
with a conscientious objector exemption
granted with no questions asked
even if a business already requires or
intends to require a vaccine this would
basically render that decision nell and
void
another thing to point out this bill
also isn't limited to copen 19 vaccine
but vaccines generally
however because the coba 19 vaccine
seems to be the immediate intent i
didn't want to point out the coping 19
vaccine is approved it's recommended it
has been proven to be safe and effective
and it is the best tool we have to end
the pandemic
the new hampshire nurses association is
opposed to hb 1210 because it would
interfere with businesses including
hospitals long-term care facilities
and other health care facilities in
terms of choosing how to best protect
the health and safety of their staff and
patients
hp 1210 takes away a tool to businesses
to health healthcare facilities
that could be used to keep their
workplaces safe and open in healthcare
settings it's important that we keep our
nurses and healthcare heroes safe and at
work and doing what they do best caring
for and protecting patients the new
hampshire nurses association urges you
to recommend itl on hb 1210 thank you
again for your time
thank you for any questions for the
presenter
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
um
the new hampshire nurses association
opposes the bill
i'm assuming you all polled the nurses
in new hampshire and
what was the percentage of nurses who
said they did not wish to take the
vaccine
the
new hampshire nurses association
represents about 1300 nurses out of
about 20 000 in the state
i'm not aware of any poll but i do know
there is data
that over 90 of nurses in the state have
been vaccinated
follow up
thank you and uh could you provide us
that data please i'd be happy to thank
you
any additional questions
ceo thank you very much gary york
followed by
ken
irving mr uh york
you requested in the uh in greater than
five minutes i'd appreciate it given the
time we have left for this hearing if
you could be concise
with your comments
thank you
members i'll try to be brief
there's a very important legislation
especially as it relates to the
conscientious objector
portion of the bill
i'm not vaccinated
i don't i'm not in the working world so
i don't have the ability to
apply for an exemption
i consider myself
pretty fit even though i'm an old fiddle
i don't have any religion
i'm not eligible for any of those
exemptions
sometimes that doesn't even matter if
you submit a religious or a medical
exemption many of these from personal
experience of people that i know are
not accepted anyway
so a conscientious objection allows for
someone like myself
and especially the younger population
to
[Music]
receive
an exemption
in this state in this country probably
one in four people have no religious
affiliation
for the younger people it's probably a
third to a half have no religious
affiliation this conscientious objection
is a very important part of this
legislation
and i do
appreciate the wording
in the bill that says and it shall be
accepted
that's very important you know you have
to accept this as someone's
request for an exemption
what i worry about
is having employers
impose what they consider a reasonable
accommodation
from an employer standpoint a reasonable
accommodation may be for an employee to
wear a face mask
maybe wear a
glass or a shield
uh
maybe
submit to weekly or bi-weekly testing
for the person who stock shelves i'm
before the stock boy or stock gal at the
market basket we can accommodate you
you can't be in front of people which i
know you enjoy but we can put you on the
11 to 7 midnight or graveyard shift
that's how we'll accommodate you
that's acceptable to the employer but
imagine how acceptable that is to the
employee
that just speaks so loudly of
discrimination
i also think that
the bill might be strengthened by
some some wording that i will uh give to
the committee uh sponsors
uh the whole cons and i'd like to
address um
the issue of someone made a comment
about this person is not unvaccinated
thus not protected and that's sort of a
i'm not sure what that even means not
protected
representative turcotte had some good
questions how do we
distinguish between someone who's not
vaccinated versus a vaccinated person
versus someone who's not an exemption
an unvaccinated person is going to be
symptomatic if they're infected
and a vaccinated person
likely
will have reduced symptoms and may be
asymptomatic
therefore
to think that an unvaccinated person
is not suitable to be
working in an oncology
[Music]
situation
because they're not safe that's an
outdated concept we know that
and most of us probably know people
who've had the vaccine and boosted up
the wazoo who actually
have had covet
they're not protected they got they got
the
disease sure maybe they've had fewer
symptoms but
there's no evidence that suggests that
someone who's vaccinated
is better
at not spreading the disease
and believe me i'm an unvaccinated
person i have no i'm not endowed with
any super
super powers that would let me infect
anyone else any more than people who are
vaccinated virus is gonna virus it's
gonna spread we don't have any
protection from that
i'd like to address comments some of the
hospital administration and other
affiliated healthcare representatives
here
they they say things like a one percent
of our
health care workers decided
we lost them because they didn't want to
get vaccinated
well remember that all these people are
being
forced to follow a mandate with coercion
you get the vaccine or you lose your job
we need this conscientious objector
status
personally
and let me let me just address the
college situation as well
someone mentioned that there was
this policy is working well for us that
is the exemption policy
that we have
a medical exemption and a religious
exemption
okay how many college
students would be eligible for a medical
exemption these are people in their the
healthiest point in their lives how many
would have a religious exemption
maybe half
that's why it's working so well
and by the way so a place like cornell
university i think it was cornell
recently had the closed down because
they had a huge outbreak sent all their
kids home
to spread the infection wherever they
live cross country across state whatever
that made no sense at all
and i'll close with just some
personal experiences i have a son who
worked as a social worker at a state a
large state health care provider
been there six years
a mandate was threatened by the
government
the company decided to
enforce the mandate straight away
he did not have the ability to give
a medical
or religious exemption
he
even if he able to give it
he needed he needed uh an ability to
give a conscientious objector
exemption but that was not present he
lost his job he was forced out of his
job
my niece worked at uh
massachusetts
large hospital association as an
oncologist
submitted a religious exemption
was denied
she was forced out and now she and her
young family have to move to
move to montana
so i completely support this bill as a
basic civil right for all new hampshire
residents thank you any questions
thank you for your testimony or any
questions for this presenter
sitting on thank you very much for your
testimony
can i ring followed by julie smith
good afternoon and thank you for the
opportunity to speak
on this bill i am in support of the bill
i'd like to start by saying opponents of
this bill based their objections on the
false premise that covid is more deadly
than it is we can barely hear you could
you speak just i know you there are
clean wipes if you don't want to get too
close to the microphone
yes thank you opponents of this bill
based their objections on the false
premise that covid is more deadly than
it is
and that the covet vaccines are safe and
effective
they are not
the covet vaccines do not work that was
admitted by the ceo of pfizer a few
weeks ago
two dozen this is a quote two doses of
the vaccine offers very limited
protection if any
the three doses with the booster offer
reasonable protection against
hospitalization and deaths
and that isn't very good and
less protection against infection
the covet vaccines don't prevent
infection they don't prevent
transmission and there are many
potential adverse side effects
therefore there must be exemptions
regarding covet vaccine mandates
there are many experts and real world
examples that provide proof that there
is no justification that the vaccine
should be mandated due to potential
dangerous side effects
including critical organ damage and
death
in october sweden and denmark halted the
use of the modern vaccination on those
30 and under due to potential side
effects a few days after that iceland
banned the modern vaccine for everyone
the american heart association concluded
the experimental gene vaccines increase
heart inflammation
anthony fauci admitted the covet
vaccines did not work as promised quote
it's waning to the point that you're
seeing more and more people getting
breakthrough infections and more and
more of those people who are getting
breakthrough infections are winding up
in the hospital
dr robert malone the inventor of the
mrna technology that is used to create
two of the vaccines the moderna and the
fisa vaccines made the following
statements
quote
this novel technology has not been
adequately tested we need at least five
years of testing and research before we
can really understand the risks
harms and risks from the new medicines
often become revealed
many years later
but
that's end quote but the data is
starting to roll in now
the one america life insurance ceo
stated that deaths are up 40
among people aged 18 to 64.
and most this is his quote most of the
claims for deaths being filed
are not classified as covet 19 deaths
that led dr robert malone the inventor
of the mrna technology to make the
following statements
quote it is starting to look to me like
the largest experiment in human beings
in recorded history has failed
at worst
this report implies that the federal
workplace vaccine mandates have driven
what appear to be a true crime against
humanity
furthermore all major mass media
and the social media technology
companies have coordinated to stifle and
suppress any discussion of the risks
of genetic vaccines
and or alternative early treatments
one of those early this is end quote
one of those early treatments is
ivermectin
the nih website calls ivermectin quote a
wonder drug unquote
dr paul merrick testified on hp 1022
last week
dr merrick has been practicing critical
care medicine for 35 years and published
over 600 peer-reviewed papers
his testimony included quote
after penicillin this is the second most
important drug ever produced it has
saved hundreds of thousands of lives
across this planet
in poor underserved countries it is on
the who's list of essential medicines
3.7 billion with a b doses have been
dispersed to humans it is safe and well
tolerated it is very effective against
rna viruses
it reduces covert mortality by half
based on the testimony of many experts
and studies and adverse reaction data it
is unconscionable to force anyone to
take an experimental drug without their
approval
this goes against the nuremberg code
there are many documented deaths and
adverse side effects due to the vaccines
many countries have used ivermectin and
other early treatments to obliterate
covin
the vaccines don't work and should not
be mandated which is why there must be
exemptions
just heard that 90 of new hampshire
nurses have been vaccinated
what you didn't hear is how many of
those nurses were forced to take that
vaccination against their will in order
to save their jobs put food on the table
for their families
i ask you to please support hb 1210
and i also ask you to keep in mind that
as of up to now
only paid special interest groups have
testified against this bill today
with all due respect you were elected to
represent the people
thank you
thank you are there any questions for
the presenter
cena thank you for your testimony
julie smith followed by rosanne chester
good afternoon committee
i'd like to thank ken irig for calling
attention to all the nurses who have
been
taken the jab under duress to keep their
jobs
and i'd also like to thank ed the
previous speaker
calling attention to the number of
people that want to be here today who
can't
and i'm here for one of them allison
dyer she's my neighbor and here are the
words she's prepared for me to say right
now
as a resident of new hampshire all my
life i have been afforded the ability to
work here i met a wonderful man and was
married here i was blessed to give birth
to a beautiful baby girl here but my
life remains here in new hampshire
because i love what new hampshire has to
offer and what new hampshire has
afforded to me and my family i am the
daughter of a nurse an icu nurse whose
career spanned 47 years my
brother-in-law a police officer in new
hampshire his wife assist my sister a
passionate employee of the church my
older sister a dental hygienist
my daughter's father an army veteran and
i myself worked in healthcare for 15
years
we have all worked in service to others
health and safety for almost 70 plus
years combined
this is
why my family and i
family of 14 eight adults and six
children all support this bill all of us
in our calling to serve and raise these
amazing little humans currently face
mandates and requirements in order to
live and in order to live in normal
day-to-day society attend school and
keep our careers
and the ability to financially care for
our families
the liberty of conscience is fundamental
in today's current climate we have a
false dilemma between faith personal
choice and one's autonomy and medical
care an individual's interpretation of
personal beliefs or religion and medical
data should not shape one's decision on
whether or not to receive an inoculation
of any kind
but the decision must still be made in
light of one's conscience this bill
would ease the pressure from employers
and institutions from being the arbiters
of their employees or students religious
beliefs
personal beliefs or one's medical
conditions that may be a barrier from
receiving any particular immunizations i
think relief relief is something so
needed and so necessary right now by
removing the obstacle from employers and
institutions to have
to make these hard calls on individual
employees and students medical religious
or personal beliefs you in turn relieve
the stress on all sides of the equations
and regain the clarity to focus on the
priorities of not only the employer
employees successes but the educational
successes as well thank you for your
time
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you roson chester
followed by kendra goodwin
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members um i wanted to start
by
just saying that i googled is our
vaccines approved by the fda
according to the fda as of january 7
2022 the covenant back the copic 19
vaccine continues to be
issued for you
eua
so this copin 19 vaccine that we keep
talking about is not currently approved
by the
food and drug administration of the
united states what i love about this
bill is it's not specific to cobit 19.
what cobit 19 has done for us is it's
forced us to understand how absolutely
critical it is that the state of new
hampshire and its residents and its
small businesses are protected by an
overhanded
potentially
not in our best interest federal
government
and that's what this bill does it
provides
our citizens and our small businesses
the opportunity to protect themselves
it does
it does it does a good job with
businesses providing with the
opportunity to be least restrictive
environment without losing workforce and
further protects new hampshire's
advantage
because we're getting a lot of folks now
because of what's going on in
massachusetts and they're finding out
that they can work at parkland and not
be vaccinated we've we've increased our
our
folks there by i think they said they
they hired 15 new staff out of state
staff in parkland medical in less than a
month
that's phenomenal um
it also puts equal responsibility on
both the the individual employee as well
as the small business
the individual employee has a
responsibility to file for an exemption
the
business has the capability
of saying i'm going to do what our state
constitution and our state legislature
has made appropriate and
be able to have a little teeth behind
them when and if they have to go up to
against the federal government
um
i heard people talk today about it would
it would um feels as though it would re
reverse process
reverse the progress we've made
and that
exemptions would increase people willing
to take the vaccine
that's basically saying
we're going to coerce and control you
until you do what we tell you
we and the people of new hampshire are
not children to be punished when we
don't do
what the federal government tells us to
do
that's what our founding fathers ensured
lastly
the other thing that i like like i said
it doesn't pertain to the coven 19
um
covid19
specific
vaccine it pertains to any medical
experimental or non-approved medical
procedure
and that's important to understand
this is not about covert 19 this is
about the next pandemic and the next
pandemic and the next oversight of the
federal government
and that being said
with regards to
um including beyond religious and
medical beliefs
religious religious and medical
exemptions
there have been a number of people that
have been denied medical exemptions
religious exemptions because their
employer or their hr feels that they are
judge and jury on what is an appropriate
religious exemption and what is not
and that ends up going to the
to the discrimination board
this putting this in there would allow
people
i truly believe that we would see
we would see a decrease in litigation
if something like this was passed
finally with regards to any type of
discrimination we already have a process
for that
let's not let's not try and create
something that's not let's not try to
fix something that's not broke
if reasonable accommodations cannot be
met
the employee has the ability to file a
complaint
it's already in effect
this doesn't change that at all
what this bill does is it allows
employees to get back to work to doing
the careers they love and it allows
employers to providing the goods and
services to the people of new hampshire
without
far overreach restrictions
just want to end on a supple
little end note
i like many people have heard about all
the terrible things of
the consequences of the this uh
covert 19 vaccine
up until this past weekend
i was not aware firsthand
i got a call from my girlfriend who
lives in florida i've known her son
since he was 10 years old he's an ems
person in
boston
he was required to continue his
employment which he loves
to take the vaccines and the booster
shots he took the booster shot on
thursday i don't know which one i didn't
ask i thought it was inappropriate
but he took the booster shot on thursday
because he posted it to
one of his
instagrams or something
friday he flew to florida to spend a
week with his mother
saturday he was found dead in bed
does anybody any employer any
legislative body
any special interest group
that is opposing this bill do you want
even one life on your conscience
i know i don't
thank you
thank you for your testimony any
questions
cena thank you very much kendra goodwin
followed by julie sims if you could be
brief i would appreciate it
hi again
so i just wanted to say that i think
this is about individual liberty and not
corporate
freedom i mean
it's all corporations now any business
and um people say
that
they're accepting exemptions and stuff i
work in a hospital system my mother
works in a hospital system my cousin in
florida works in a hospital system they
are denying
exemptions they are denying religious
exemptions they deny medical exemptions
and it's almost impossible to get a
medical exemption because doctors won't
write them in fear of losing their
license
and people who say oh they're safe and
effective safe and effective my
boyfriend his best friend's girlfriend
was 32 years old eight months pregnant
she got her vaccine she died a week
later in her sleep and she had a brain
full of blood clots
that's not that's not a coincidence to
me i mean that's
that's pretty uh i mean what 32 year old
just gets brain full of blood clots for
no reason and there's actually doctors
out there that are doing these studies
and they're actually testing people say
oh i feel fine after my vaccine how do
you know did you have your blood work
done did you have your t cells checked
did you have your d dimers checked no
they're not and they're finding that
a lot of these people are decimating
their t-cell production
which you need to fight
disease and if you i pay attention close
attention to israel and uk numbers and i
actually have it right from their
government website vaccinated
individuals are now getting coveted are
hospitalized from covenant dying from
clovid at much higher rates than the
unvaccinated and that's rates not
raw numbers
and a lot of it i believe is from
your t-cells because you're training
your body to only make antibodies and
you're not making your t cells anymore
which you need to fight respiratory
viruses
and and we also working at the hospital
i can assure you that every hospital
right now is having huge outbreaks of
covet among their employees
and they're all vaccinated
and you know they'll say oh well you
have it more mild if you're vaccinated
that's not true i had covered three
weeks ago i had it mild i was over it in
two days
so i mean this whole notion that oh it's
mild if you're vaccinated i mean that
they don't you can't possibly know that
it's an assumption
i'm unvaccinated and i had it mild i
could i have vaccinated family that got
covered and had it worse than i did that
would be like me saying oh thank god i'm
not vaccinated i would have had it so
much worse
it's just it's crazy even if if the
shots worked there's no reason to
mandate them because you're protected it
wouldn't matter whether i have or not if
they don't work it makes no sense either
i mean it just doesn't make any sense
and in fact i think the hospitals are
putting more people in danger by
allowing if you're vaccinated you can
come back after five days and expose all
your patients to cope it
um
see if there's anything else i wanted to
say
i'll just leave it at that for now okay
thank you with any questions
sing none i hold the last pink card in
my hand
julie
well this is my sims time so god help
you
all right um
i support this bill very very much
sorry
um i support this bill very very much
and i will tell you why
my daughter is 23 years old and she's in
college
and
she is
having a hard time because she has she
she has to get vaccinated but she will
not and she's being very segregated
into um
in another room
she's being bullied
she's
it's disgusting
i i'm very disgusted right now
she lost four jobs
she
i can't even
i cry every day for her
the vaccine is is killing people
by the day
and she's
you know my daughter is the world to me
kids are the world to me
even when they're not mine
and um
she's just
she can't find a job because of the
vaccine mandates
this has to stop
it it's just it has to stop
and i guess that's it thank you
thank you for your testimony
uh any questions
i have no additional pink cards to say
what else like to speak on this bill
yes you may be recognized briefly please
employers always you know mandate
certain
things like
hard hat or safety measures those safety
measures you can take your mask off
after you can take your helmet off you
can't undo an injection
there should always be informed consent
with any medical procedure
thank you brian
no i'm fine right now that's right
i'm good
i'm going to close the hearing
on
house bill
house bill 110
and open the hearing
on house bill 1351.
i only have one
card to speak that's
from steve hearn do i have anyone to
present the bill
is
i know we're late but representative
is representative silber here to present
his bill
uh representative seaworth would you
please uh
open uh the hearing on this and present
the bill
uh is it okay if i do it without it is
all right thank you uh mr chairman i
would like to introduce representative
seaworth uh from representing pembroke
in chichester and vice chair of this
committee i would like to introduce
house bill 1351
and not being a sponsor i'll say no more
all right thank you very much i have two
pink cards steve ahern from new
hampshire
hospital association
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee again for the record my
name is stephen i'm the president of
hampshire hospital association i
provided a testimony i'm here
representing all of our hospitals
as you can probably well imagine i
opposed to house bill 1351 for many of
the same reasons we were opposed to the
last bill
i guess i just want to take the
opportunity to
say
what hospitals are doing is attempting
to try to protect the health and safety
of their patients and to protect their
ability to care for all of their
patients you know the omicron surge has
certainly seen a huge increase in the
number of patients that we're seeing
truly being overwhelmed you know the
hospital association conducts daily
huddles every day with our hospitals to
help them manage the capacity
it's not just covet patients that
they're caring for it's non-covered
patients our hospitals are incredibly
full finding a bed a med surg bed a
traditional hospital bed finding an icu
bed can be incredibly challenging our
hospitals have worked valiantly over
these past years to make sure that every
patient can get the care they need when
and where they need it that's becoming
more and more difficult as we see an
overwhelming number of people who are
becoming infected with covet 19 they're
they're ending up in the hospital and
that is the burden that we're trying to
address and to to reduce that burden so
that every patient can get the care they
need when and where they need it whether
they're vaccinated unvaccinated whether
they have covet or whether they're the
victim of an automobile accident a heart
attack or something else we need to do
everything we can to reduce the burden
to ensure the health and safety of our
workforce our patients and our
communities
i'd be happy to take any questions
thank you you have any questions for the
presenter
cnn thank you very much i call on teresa
treviowski followed by ken
eyring
good afternoon uh committee members is
my first time doing this
and i um
and for this bill
and all the other ones presented today
and i think the statement will
cover each area in one statement
and if i may add something at the end
that i forgot to write down i'll just
throw that
i got to be honest with you i didn't
hear that last sentence if you speak
close to the microphone if i
may after i read my statement i have one
more thing to say
that i don't have in here
so my name is teresa travisacci
i am a resident of dairy since last year
i'm an rn going into my 12th year
practice and prior to that worked as a
tech giving support to nurses
in hospitals and nursing homes for 12
years
i would like to give some more personal
context without violating hipaa to the
bills proposed today
and i am in support of all in the fall
of 2019 i took a job as a travel nurse
and worked in the boston area
when kovit hit the boston area in the
spring of 2020 my love and i got sick
for me it was mild
have had worse clues for tony it was a
bit worse his doctor threw a telemedical
said yes it sounds like you have the
virus
and prescribed an inhaler
instead of symptoms get worse go to the
hospital
when picking up his script i also bought
vitamin c
he had one rough night but got through
it without going to the hospital
good food supplements fresh air and
sunshine all helped his recovery
when i returned to work i worked all the
coveted units all the med surg
i was a helper in the icus
for approximately seven to eight weeks
after a short period of time i
recognized a pattern of who was getting
sick enough to be hospitalized
and shared with the docs our experience
and asked if they had looked into at
other drugs over the counter
anything that people can take at the
first sign of symptoms
to my surprise their reactions were of
fear they had fear over their faces
one doc said it's all dependent on viral
load
my response was of course
but that doesn't mean you can't try to
prevent hospitalization and death
his response we don't have time
we're too busy treating those in the
hospital
with just one protocol
that was experimental
i did see a few patients getting iv high
dose vitamin c and iv multivitamins
in may of 2020 i had a patient with
rheumatoid arthritis
on hydroxychloroquine
came in for severe covet
oxygen saturation of 86
and a fever
now before you start pointing fingers
and say see hcq doesn't work i argue it
kept this patient out of the icu
they were given the room to severe and
low dose steroids by day five the
patient only required one liter of
oxygen at night
the patient was discharged home with
supplemental oxygen in total they just
needed a little more time to recover and
could do that at home
three days later the patient returned
all symptoms had returned and required
three liters of oxygen
again
on the second day of this patient's
readmission i got a report that the docs
were probably going to discharge this
patient after not doing anything just
had been monitoring
i reviewed all the labs notes
assessed the patient and asked more
questions
my conclusion was they are not looking
at this patient's immune system or
rather the lack thereof
i contacted the doc and said just that
ask them to at least try iv vitamin c
the doc said i like where you're going
with this and they tested the patient
for antibodies
and they had none
the patient was given donor antibodies
from recovered cova patients
discharged the next day not needing
supplemental oxygen
one size does not fit all
in fact
two patients with the same diagnosis
may be treated
with some of the same things but
tailored to their needs
in that same month the covet recovering
patient had developed c diff this is an
intestinal infection
and going septic
the doc said very flippantly
the protocol states after one round of
antibiotics there's no need to treat
again
i i reiterated the clinical status of
the patient that c diff was a cyclical
infection and quite frankly your
protocol is inaccurate
now that this patient has been in the
hospital for nearly eight weeks
recovering slowly you're going to let
them die from a treatable intestinal
infection
the doc put the order in to have the
stool sample evaluated for c diff the
sample was positive and the patient was
treated with a new drug and stabilized
also in that month
the negative pressure system on one unit
failed
what that does is filter the air
multiple times from the patient's rooms
before circulating elsewhere
that system failure
was corrected approximately 25 minutes
later
during that time the air from the
patient's rooms who were all covered
circulated on that unit and possibly to
other units
hepa filter fans were placed on all
units we were all told to put on our
n95s and eye shields and report to them
if we got sick
eight staff on that unit where the leak
occurred got sick
the paper masks do not work
fast forward to the spring of 2021
with the roll out of the vaccines
i had many questions which which i could
not find the answers
and was not willing to play russian
roulette with experimental gene therapy
i had finally found dr peter mccullough
and his early treatment protocol finally
reports were coming out from around the
world on effective
treatments all could be modified for the
patient's needs
in late april i started seeing vaccine
injury
heart attacks strokes
unexplained severe infections not
responding to antibiotics guillain-barre
syndrome
sudden and advanced onset of lewy body
dementia more commonly known as mad cow
disease
this is basically dementia with
hallucinations
seizures increasing cancers
and a strange phenomenon in severe low
platelet counts
intestines and arteries perforating with
no known cause
again i tried challenging the docs in
many instances
i could see the attempted cover up with
inappropriate diagnosis and unwilling to
scan with an mri which is a higher
resolution than ct scan
i witnessed people's lives being
destroyed
what a reasonable person
after having coveted at home
working a solid to eight weeks of covet
only
getting mildly ill
what a reasonable person with critical
thinking skills
take this risk with an experimental gene
therapy vaccine
let alone a person like me that
traditional vaccines don't work for
one size does not fit all
now we see this gene therapy is failing
not working
yet employers in hospitals are requiring
boosters
you might get an exemption if you're
lucky
i chose to walk away
from my travel position
i wasn't going to jump through hoops
have to prove i was not sick
i sold my place in connecticut and
purchased a clnc educational program
this is a certification program to
become a legal nurse consultant to
attorneys
for or against personal injury medical
malpractice workman's comp just to name
a few
bedside nursing has been my passion
and because of these mandates i had to
walk away
it was like a scene out of the twilight
zone
most of those i worked with
just rolled over
threw away critical thinking
and marched to the beat of a new drum
now i'm labeled a conspiracy theorist an
anti-vaxx an unclean person
sound familiar
this is similar to the propaganda
perpetrated on the german people in the
1930s
this date gives me a little bit of hope
you the lawmakers you uphold the
constitution and our rights
to our bodies
that just maybe this little mighty
freedom state
can legis legislate us away
from madness and tyranny
in regards to this bill this should
include all employers and hospitals
and at the end i just would like to add
that all through the summer tony and i
went all around
massachusetts new hampshire connecticut
didn't get sick delta delta plus delta
whatever you want to call it was going
around
then omicron came along
we went and visited family and my family
in connecticut
and stopped at one place where the
cashier
wearing a mess and pulling it down
coughing hacking sneezing watering eyes
there was you know plastic and i was
like oh boy
well i had taken my prophylactic guy
vermectin
that evening when we were driving home
i started getting hot
then the next morning i had a sore
throat a headache body aches
so i called my mom
i said hey just let you know on the way
home i didn't feel well
this is what i'm having this morning
you know
make sure you're taking everything that
you need to be taking
and let me know if anything happens
so it took me about a week and during
the course of that illness which it
could have been a cold it could have
been covered it could have been the flu
these treatments treat them all
i realized my vitamin d level was low
what i was taking to supplement wasn't
enough
i boosted it up
the next day my symptoms were completely
gone
i did the right thing by staying home i
didn't go out and if i was working
as i had always done in the past if i
had woken up with any symptoms i would
take responsibility and not go into work
i've been in contact with nurses around
the country
they say now the unvaccinated
workers have to wear n95s all the time
this is a very difficult thing to do for
any length of time
that the vaccinated nurses don't have to
be tested
and in fact they're the ones getting
sick during the course of their shift
and even kind of bragging about it being
arrogant about it
they don't care that they could possibly
be putting somebody else their
co-workers or their patients
at risk
because they are kind of getting away
with it
thank you for your time thank you for
your testimony any questions of the
presenter
saying none thank you very much pink
card for dave juve but i don't see he's
here so would go to mr uh ken
hiring and then karen sweeting
ken
you're recognized i thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to this honorable body
i urge you to support this bill
i'd like i wish it would be for all
organizations and companies
but
you know i still support this bill
because it's important
everything that i said on the previous
bill i don't want to repeat but that's
the basis of why i'm here
i want to emphasize that
no one should be compelled to take an
experimental vaccine
the vaccines that are available now
that people are being injected with all
of them are experimental
pfizer has an approved vaccine called
kubernate
that is not available in the country
forcing somebody to take that
is against the nurbur code
the
covet death statistics that were used
to justify
this pandemic
the cdc has gone back and adjusted those
numbers and
people who were previously declared to
have died
from coven
94 of those people are now declared to
have died with coped and that they died
from one of their co-morbidities
if you look at the death
deaths
totals by year over the past five years
you'll see that there is no death spike
based on any
like based on code or for any other
reason
so that justifies
the fact that they change the numbers
to reflect the fact that most of these
people didn't die from coven
it can be and like i said earlier kobe
can be treated with other natural
treatments or not natural treatments but
cheap and effective treatments
and it's important to realize that so
the purpose of
this bill which would which would be to
prevent people from being
forced to take a vaccination before they
would be hired
goes against all reason and logic and i
know
if you haven't read all the things that
i've read from all the experts the true
experts the people who have invented the
technology and the people who have been
there in the trenches
it might be hard to believe
that but i encourage you to do so and if
you have questions
i'd be happy to uh to provide any data
that you'd like to see
i again i ask that you support this bill
it's important it's a basic human right
to determine what gets injected into
your body and there should be no
restraints on or
you should not be have to be coerced
into doing so in order to have
employment so you could put food on the
table for your family thank you
thank you justin any questions
sitting down thank you
karen sweeting
thank you mr chairman thank you for all
members of the committee to hear my
testimony today
i'm actually representing myself as a
resident of the lakes region of new
hampshire
you know as i sit and listen to all the
different testimonies
this isn't about republican or democrat
this isn't about vaccinated or not
vaccinated
you know this is really about
what is the real problem here
it's it's a man-made synthetic s-spike
protein that was created in a wuham lab
i've been a pharmaceutical
representative for 18 years and it's not
about conspiracy theory it's about can
we all just do our due diligence to do
the research so when i was forced and
faced with the decision to either keep
my job or get a vaccination
i was terminated from my job it was not
honored the opportunity through title
vii of the u.s constitution the right to
be accommodated for a religious or
medical exemption and i was denied that
so
i've spoken spent the last 18 years
educating cardiologists hematologists
oncologists on how the mechanism of
action of medications work and thank god
we have medications when they're needed
and appropriate and necessary
but at what cost do the benefits or the
risks what's what's the ratio how many
people need to die how many people need
to be injured where there's no
accountability for any of these deaths
or any of these injuries and then people
are losing their jobs in their
livelihood
so i i just want us to figure out how do
we really step back and look at what is
the real problem here
the problem is we don't have accurate
information out in the mainstream media
of what these vaccines are really all
about they're not vaccines it's a gene
therapy
it's a gene therapy and so if there's
people that have been vaccinated or not
vaccinated
if you've been vaccinated why are you
worried about anyone that's not been
vaccinated
why does anthony fauci have profits and
royalties in the modern patent
why does the cdd cdc have investments
in the pfizer and or modern vaccines
this doesn't make sense at what cost
does the the human life
what is i'm just dumbfounded and
devastated of what's happening not only
in the state of new hampshire but in our
country
it's just really really unfortunate and
i can only hope and pray that we are
able to come up so these vaccines and
these vaccine mandates i am totally
against the vaccine mandates i'm against
the vaccines and i just hope and pray
that as this these bills are brought
forward whether it's the the mandate i
support both bills here today
there should be no mandates so much
someone should have to decide on whether
they take a vaccine where
it's supposed to be informed consent go
to any pharmacy ask them to show you the
package insert of any of these vaccines
why do they not list the ingredients
that are in these vaccines
if they are safe and effective i think
anyone that says that they are safe and
effective is because they're getting
federal fund from the cares act
and i understand and i feel for any of
these administrators that are dealing
with nurses associations or hospital
associations you need funds to keep your
organizations going but at what cost
that's the overreach of our government
and that's what the us constitution is
for
so i support both of these bills that
are here for us today i'll take any
questions if you have any thank you for
your testimony or any questions
for your time sitting on thank you very
much
it's the last card i have anyone else
want to speak on house bill 1351.
behind
you could try to be brief sir i
appreciate it
i'm gary york from hopkinton new
hampshire sadly
as a physician i have to admit that the
medical profession has kind of failed us
over the past couple of years
and it may be for a number of reasons
but when i first started my practice it
was a private practice group most of the
other clinical practices were private
practice
over years up to
the time of my retirement six years ago
physicians gradually
had to join corporate medicine these
were
individually hospital owned medical
groups
they were forced into that over time
because insurance companies would not
reimburse private practice people and
the more competitive rates were to be
found with hospital groups
some of the decisions made by these uh
corporations now are from administrators
from on high
and things like mandates and
requirements that medical staff be
vaccinated come from
administrators and other
people high up on the
organization
if physicians
are
here's here's the problem
physicians were afraid to
allow early treatment for covid and
there were there were
treatments known
for fear of
not following
guidelines by the corrupt cdc
center for disease control disease
control do you think that in two years
the center for disease control would
have had any widespread nationwide
clinical trials for early treatment of
covid no
because we haven't we have to push the
vaccine
we're not going to allow things like
vitamin i hybrid mechanism we're not
going to do that
we have to get the vaccine out
so i think
the whole
way that the nation has handled this
across the past two years has been a
real failure
and from i could give a number of
different examples but from a medical
professional standpoint
i think
physicians are
number one they're coerced they can't
speak freely
for fear of losing their job and these
are mandates that are being
come down from
on high from hospital administrators
thank you
thank you for your testimony any
questions for the presenter
see none thank you very much i'm going
to close the hearing
on house bill 1351 representative
seaworth would you please come to the
podium and take over house bill
and we're going to call
greg hoff
to present his bill
greg if you could do that from out in
front i appreciate it
uh just a question of the chairman
yes um is has dhhs
president to answer some questions about
their section uh i'm sorry lino i can't
hear you i cannot hear you dhhs
president to ask some questions
are they are they
department of health and human services
is anyone here from the stat state
department
i'm going to open the public hearing on
if or did you do that it's already open
on 1352
and i recognize
representative huff
sponsor of this legislation
thank you mr chairman and honorable
members of the labor committee
is
another covet build
i want to thank the the chair for
putting these all together because a lot
of questions
are answered and we get a lot of insight
on this in this particular bill
it's it's a simple premise and that is
is that this bill provides that if an
adverse reaction happens
and we've seen today and we've heard
today that they do
if an employer is to mandate
a vaccine
as a
term of keeping your job
and something happens
this would be able to have the person
who is harmed
filed for workman's comp
a couple of points i'd like to make out
just to give you an idea
since 1989
the average number of all vaccine
related deaths in new hampshire that
were
reported
combined
that's over 32 years
is somewhere in the neighborhood of
about 10 a year
in the first seven months of the coveted
vaccines
55 people in new hampshire had died
that's in two-thirds of a year
and and that kind of result has happened
this comes from the the affairs site the
cdc
fda
the premise here is if businesses are
going to force workers
people
to inject their bodies with potentially
dangerous chemicals
as a condition of employment
then they should bear responsibility for
those consequences
and as in as you heard in earlier
testimony i just want to emphasize a
point here because
earlier it was mentioned
that
in labor
we try not to stand in between employer
and employee
and i want to emphasize that we don't
want to tell businesses what to do
but since it's the employer's decision
to adopt such a policy a policy that may
injure people
in ways that we can't predict or even
understand yet
then the employer should have the
responsibility
if harm comes to those employees
so this would just simply
give the employees
some sort of relief
in the case of an adverse reaction and
with that i'll take any questions
thank you are there any questions
thank you chairman mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
representative two quick questions if
you don't mind um
one in line well throughout the the bill
it mentions covet 19. is there any
reason why you've limited it to covet 19
and not
injections or other
types of vaccinations
thank you for the for the question um
that's the thing that was on the mind i
would absolutely be open to an amendment
to to make that a little bit more broad
for
any any type of forced or required
injections
follow-up
thank you thank you for your answer and
uh the only other question is
um
who were what would be the determining
individual
to determine if the actual
reaction adverse reaction was caused by
an injection
that would have to be
from a physician i would assume
um i didn't have that in here
specifically because an adverse reaction
could be
a
a number of things we've heard different
degrees of adverse reactions from uh
actually getting the flu
all the way to death and in
uh
i believe uh gion
bears disease
ra
and a lot of other different things so i
think it would be something that would
manifest itself
after you got it you would go to your
physician and if that there was
something wrong then that would be
the determining factor on whether or not
there was a problem thank you thank you
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
thank you for members of the committee
next i'd like to
call on
deputy commissioner rudy ogden
he is neither in support or in
opposition to the bill
good afternoon uh thank you
representative seaworth i'm happy to
answer any questions one thing that we
did want to comment on relative to this
bill because we have had certain
questions come in relative to the
proposed legislation is first just in
terms of context it is important to know
that
even if there is no legislative change
here these types of adverse reactions at
least on an arguable basis would be
compensable under workers comp and what
i mean by that is under existing law
under existing application of law if
someone has a flu shot as is required by
their employer and they have an adverse
reaction they can make a claim for
workers comp benefits under existing law
so i just want to be very clear that
there is an existing mechanism or
apparatus for those claims to be made
that being said if what the intent here
is to put in place a presumption
there are other places in workers comp
law namely a given example of 281 a17c
where there is a presumption put into
law saying that if a first responder or
i think it's actually an emergency
responder has ptsd or acute stress
disorder that condition is presumed to
be occupationally related i'd point out
that the use of the word presumed is
impactful in the sense that presumed
under workers comp law it typically
means that okay there's a presumption
that it's occupationally related but the
employer or more specifically their
carrier could still deny the claim if
they felt that they were entitled to
rebut the presumption so essentially
what a presumption does is it shifts the
balance from okay i'm the claimant i
need to make and pursue my claim to
instead saying okay the employer needs
to deny the claim and they have the
burden to discount it so i just want to
put out there that if the intent here is
to put in a presumption
arguably it might be better served to
use the presumption language that's
elsewhere in the law as that might be
more easily applied the other thing that
we point out relative to a concern or
consideration relative to ongoing
administration
we had questions concerning the language
quote shall be eligible if i look at
lines
bear with me for one second line six and
seven of the proposed bill where it says
quote shall be eligible for workers comp
benefits under the chapter we would just
be seeking guidance or i think perhaps
additional clarity what exactly is the
extent of that how expansive are we to
take that does that mean that if there
was an adverse reaction that the
individual having that adverse reaction
would be entitled to any and all
benefits forever
again i think that that's why again it
might be worth referencing or looking to
the presumption language because under
the presumption language it's presumed i
would say in practice most presumed
injuries or incidents they're accepted
as claims and you'll have the follow-on
payment or care from the carrier but
under the presumption model the carrier
or the employer does still have the
right to issue or make denials and again
that would address under this existing
language we just have questions over
whether any claim could ever be denied
so again say there's an adverse reaction
say i missed some work say i have a
couple medical appointments but what if
three months later i put in another you
know okay now i want to get this done or
i want to get that done so i would just
put out there that under this proposed
legislation the department would say
arguably anything that the person seeks
and says in some way flows from that
adverse reaction they'd be entitled to
so i'm happy to take any questions but
we just wanted to offer that context
thank you very much for that i will
recognize representative prout and then
representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman and thank you
commissioner for taking my question um
you stated earlier that uh if someone
has an adverse reaction to other
vaccines say that you i think use the
example the flu shot it will be
evaluated under where comes compensation
uh today is that only if the employer
had mandated that flu shot i assume
no so again in the general sense if the
person is saying that there
have an injury and workers comp the
issue or the evaluation is always is it
occupationally related if the person
made the claim that
i got this flu shot because of work
that's what made it more likely for me
to get it
to get the flu shot
even if it wasn't mandated i think that
you could have an argument but certainly
under the mandate and you'd have a
stronger argument
follow up
um
thank you for that answer um
so
do you see a section b or c of the bill
which specify non-mandate related
enticements as qualifying as adding
anything to that evaluation or is that
already completely covered on the
existing framework that you were just
speaking about
again we were looking at b and c of the
proposed legislation as kind of defining
the parameters of what a mandate is so
mandate was not just a strict it's
required but a mandate would also be
taken as an incentive or enticement so
i guess i don't know if i'm answering
your questions but i don't know that it
necessarily changes uh the analysis or
would change anything under
existing law it would just make it more
clear that it's
required
thank you
representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here
deputy commissioner
um
you referred to adverse reactions who
determines
whether a
medical condition after a vaccination
for a flu or for covid who determines
whether some medical condition is indeed
an adverse reaction or just a
coincidental medical condition
so i thank you for the question
representative sullivan representative
turcotte had asked a question along that
those lines earlier
looking at the proposed legislation it
does define an adverse reaction sickness
disease trauma injury or condition
arising
so basically if they were not sick
before and now they're sick
ultimately you would need some
determination likely from a medical
provider or something in which they're
able to then say okay that's supporting
a report of this injury or report of
this reaction i do think that the
department in evaluating those things
would not just be looking from someone
saying they felt sick i think they would
like some type of
likely a provider making some type of
qualification or determination
representative infantine
thank you mr chairman
mr ogden
you talked about the presumptive
where in law
would we find that and the reason why i
ask
is would would the same thing occur if
you removed the word shall in line six
to may
or would you just strike that all
together and what was the other language
the presumptive language and where is
that found in law
so
thank you representative
and i would look at there's a couple
different places the one that i
specifically reference in my testimony
is 281 a17c
and it just literally in talking about
first responders or emergency responders
and acute stress disorder just puts out
that there shall be a presumption
that it's occupationally related i think
the use of presumption is purposeful in
the sense that that's a known legal term
it's it's come up in the context of
comp claims and
whether you know all the way up to the
supreme court that you know if there's a
presumption uh the important thing is
the presumption
shifts the burden it's assumed or
presumed that it's occupationally
related but still the carrier employer
would have the wherewithal to say for
certain reasons the presumption could be
rebutted so i don't know if that answers
your question but it's elsewhere in law
in terms of in 281 a there are certain
sections also 281 a17 dealing with heart
and lung disease there's a couple
different areas mainly in the first
responder context dealing with
presumptions of occupational uh related
hazards
please follow up
mr ogden i'm just concerned
with making this presumptive
at this point
and going back to a regular type of
claim
where
someone makes a claim insurance company
or the employer does the investigation
they have the ability to go back if they
don't get the result they want they can
go for a hearing with you folks so i go
back to my
line six without putting this into a
presumptive
part of the law
would may versus shall
solve some of your concerns whether it's
a guarantee
that you will get the benefits
regardless
in response to that i'd say if you want
it to be a guarantee i think the shall
be considered occupational disease i
think that that's workable if you want
it as a guarantee i would leave it as
shall be the department's concern would
then be the following shall shall be
eligible for workers comp if that was
changed to a may that would address our
concern
in terms of administration going forward
is is there ever an opportunity for
denial
that's what that's where i met the first
all right
all right thank you
uh representative abellani
thank you mr chairman and thank you
deputy commissioner um would there be a
time frame on this
typical workman's case
workman's comp places have to be claimed
within 48 hours of injury
where is the timeline where what would
you be looking for for guidance on a
timeline for this
well
this does not in any way
for our review alter the existing time
frames for reporting injury so i think
that you'd be within that you know the
18-month type of you have 18 months for
appeal but you're looking for the
employer to report within five days
but the employer doesn't necessarily
report until they're notified by the
employees so i don't think this changes
any of those timelines so we wouldn't be
looking for anything special or
particular
it would just be do you have a notice of
injury reported are they seeking the
claim within 18 months
of having provided notice
are there any other questions for the
department of labor
representative cahill
thank you mr chair thank you mr ogden
how would one determine like if six
eight months down the road after the
vaccination someone had a heart attack
people have heart attacks or strokes how
would we determine that that was caused
by a
vaccine
i think that's a good question i think
that again with with this what we would
be looking for
is it is there an adverse reaction
within 14 days so we'd be looking for 14
days from the vaccine do we have some
type of adverse reaction if you're
talking about
they've had an adverse reaction and then
sometime thereafter they've had a heart
attack i think that you would have to
tie them together somehow i don't know
exactly how they would do that or could
do that but they would have to if
they're saying the heart attack was
related to the earlier injury they would
have to make that case or claim
thank you
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
your testimony
um i have a card here from mr juve
who i don't see with us in the room
um
the next card is from laura condon
she
did not mark whether she is in support
or oppose the bill so if you could say
good afternoon my name is laura condon
again i'm a volunteer director of
advocacy with the national vaccine
information center and we're an
educational resource advocacy
and we advocate for informed consent for
vaccination
while it is clear this bill has good
intentions and i very much appreciate
the efforts of the sponsors i have
concerns with the bill that is written
it would actually limit and reduce
workers compensation protections already
available to employees subject to covet
vaccine mandates or injured or killed by
these mandatory shots
specifically my concerns are two points
here
the 14 day limit for an injury claim
will deny many
rightful compensation having worked with
a vaccine injured for many many years i
can attest that many do not immediately
recognize the symptoms of vaccine injury
14 days can easily pass before the
connection is made a person may
experience back or shoulder pain that
they do not recognize as vaccine related
to perhaps a symptom of myocarditis into
14 days
yet they may later suffer a heart attack
serious heart damage or death
open beer shows that 110 deaths
helps to track the bears reports and it
shows here that 110 deaths actually
reported at 20 days
28 days out so that certainly partly
time limit here
um in addition perhaps this bill should
be modeled after the national vaccine
injury compensation program that allows
for claims for injury from vaccines that
occur
within three years after first symptoms
of the injury
this provides for the time to complete
necessary medical evaluation and testing
number two the bills should provide
compensation for death
to date there have been 22 193
reports of deaths in the united states
and 64 deaths right here in new
hampshire following covet vaccination
this is per the the viers reporting
system
actual deaths are most certainly much
higher than
reported to theirs
you might ask what is veers viirs is the
government's post marketing safety data
reporting system now there are those
that will cast out on the beers reports
and in doing so they would cast out on
the very programs that the cdc and the
fda rely on to evaluate vaccine safety
remember that filing a false mayor's
report
is a federal crime if you cast out on
the bears reporting system what is the
valid safety reporting system for
vaccines is there none
i would like to mention that the
insurance industry is noticing an
increase in death claims in this past
year and the working age population not
those over age 80.
earlier this month the life insurance
ceo from one america life in indiana
reported that deaths are up 40
among people ages 18 to 64 and most of
the claims for deaths are being being
filed are not classified as covades
what is killing our working age
population in such great numbers this
past year
i'm skipping over some things i can
email you to email to you many
businesses are choosing not to impose
any vaccine mandate even if covid19
vaccines eventually obtain fda approval
and are made available
this may be very wise avoidance of
liability for illness disability and
death caused by such vaccine mandates
many people are unaware that the
national childhood vaccine injury act of
1986 acknowledged vaccine injury and
deaths and it provides a compensation
program for those who are injured and
killed provides advisory committee and
larger shields manufacturers and
administrators from liability for harm
caused by vaccines
while the federal law may shield
manufacturers and vaccine administrators
from liability for harm
this federal law does not provide
immunity from liability protection for
private businesses organizations schools
or associations who may attempt to
independently impose their own vaccine
requirements absent any law requiring
that they do so
i understand that many may first think
that vaccines are safe and effective and
mandating their use will protect their
employees customers patrons and yes from
the harm of viral illness
but the science and reality is much more
complicated than that simple sales pitch
those who independently mandate the use
of cova vaccines will assume the
liability of harm that results from many
such mandates
then there are others who may think that
the prep act provides immunity from
liability for all cove and 19
vaccinators for all covet 19 vaccinators
but that's not true either
you look to the prep act the prep act
provides immunity from liability for
licensed health professionals authorized
to administer code 19 vaccines and
certain other individuals identified by
hhs to administer coded vaccines no such
immunity from liability has been
extended to any and all types of
businesses who may impose a covered
vaccine mandate
but is this bill even necessary
i see nothing in statute that will
prevent the payment of workers
compensation claims for all employer
workplace mandates including a vaccine
mandate while vaccine mandates are new
requirements there is no provision that
would exclude workers compensation
coverage
i made inquiry to the insurance to new
hampshire insurance department some
months ago and that yielded a
non-committal response given the newness
of the issue is expected that his
employees file claims if there is any
dispute about coverage the matter would
go to a hearing and they would look to
statute for guidance
absent any statute limiting or
preventing coverage for a workplace
requirement that injures it seems
reasonable to believe that these vaccine
injury claims would already be covered
by workers compensation
and employers who impose these covered
vaccine mandates may pray that there is
workers compensation coverage as it
certainly would be expected that an
injured employee would have civil case
against his or her employer for imposing
a vaccine mandate that caused injury
disability or death so again
i'm not convinced that this bill is
needed but if you are to consider it at
the very least the time frame for filing
a claim for injury should be extended to
three years the same time frame for
finance claim and the federal vaccine
injury compensation program
and the bills should be amended to
clearly cover disability and death
not just illness and injury i sincerely
thank the sponsors for bringing this
bill forward for discussion
employers who are injured by covered
child media mandates in the workplace
should be filing workers compensation
claims and not burning health insurance
and paying out of pocket for deductibles
and uncovered care
they deserve the full coverage of
workers compensation and should be
filing claims now
an employer who imposes a workplace
mandate should be liable for the safety
of that workplace mandate thank you very
much
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
seeing none
i have a card from paula minahan who
represents the new hampshire hospital
association
opposing the bill
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
paula minihan senior vice president
state government relations with the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals in the
state we do have concerns about this
bill and as stated by
deputy commissioner ogden we
there is question for us as to whether
or not this bill is even necessary
it seems like current law does allow for
an individual to file workers comp claim
if they had an adverse reaction to an
employer-required vaccine
what we find confusing it is b and c of
the bill
why wouldn't the way we read it is it
says or so why would an employee file a
workers comp claim if an employer
imposes additional requirements and who
declines to receive a covet vaccine and
then if they provide a bonus to an
employee it's confusing to us
and i i think that we'll just leave our
comments at that i don't think this we
don't believe this bill is necessary and
we do not support it um and thank you
for the time
to provide our comments thank you for
your testimony are there questions
seeing none thank you very much
the only other card i have is from dave
duvet who i do not see in the room
i don't have any other pink cards
was there anybody else who wished to
testify
seeing no one i will close the public
hearing on hb 1352
and we have about a minute and a half
until our next scheduled bill
that is for people without a program in
front of them we're going to at 145 here
hb 1358
and so far i have a couple of cards on
that
i don't have a card for a sponsor
on hb
1358 if there's one present could you
please fill out a pink card for me
mr chairman
oh yes i i did not i i do have your card
i did not realize you were one of the
sponsors thank you very much
yep
i'm going to run
is
again any members of the committee if
you need to step out and get something
to eat or drink
i'll feel
free to do so
although my mother probably doesn't
appreciate that i talk about her it is
11 45 and she wants me to be on time
so i'm going to open the hearing on
house bill 1358
and introduce representative william
foster
thank you mr chairman
for the record
i am representative william foster from
hillsborough county five i'm here today
to introduce
house bill 1358
requiring public and private employers
to establish procedures and exceptions
for the use of mandatory intrusive
testing as condition
of new or continued employment
in that the state of new hampshire has
affirmed in statute the natural and
essential and inherent right
to individual body integrity
and in that our state constitution
proclaims that no subject shall be hurt
molested or restrained in his body
liberty or state for worshiping god in
the manner and season most agreeable to
the dictates of his own conscience
it is therefore a lot illogical
that decisions in regards
to each individual's physical body shall
be whenever possible the free choice of
the individual
in a manner most agreeable to the
dictates of their own conscience and
reason
it was from this line of reasoning that
house bill 1358 was created
there was not that i could find anywhere
in statute
defining
what type of testing
could be required for employment by the
state
or
by private entities
to what
depth that
testing would go
and so the first thing i sought to do
with this bill and i seek to do with
this bill
is to define
um
intrusive testing as meaning any medical
testing that requires the penetration or
invasion of an individual's body through
their skin
or the penetration of any body orifice
and i sought
to establish
that
if a company wants an employee whether
it's public or private
to undergo testing that involves that
that the employee has the right to
request an exemption from it
and that the employer should grant that
exemption
um
i did this by
amending rsa
275 and inserting a new section 275 41e
discrimination based on testing exempt
status
and it does four things it defines
intrusive testing
it establishes that public or private
employer in the state
that mandates intrusive testing
as a condition of new or continued
employment shall upon the employee's
request for a religious or conscientious
objector exemption
grant that exemption
and
it also establishes that any public
private employer in the state that's
mandated intrusive testing
of a
using a
emergency use or experimental product
for that testing
shell upon the employee's request grant
an exception
and the second thing that it really does
is it directs the employers
mandating the testing to establish
policies and procedures that ensure no
employee is harassed or discriminated
against
due to that employee's testing exemption
status
and basically what it does there is it's
basically saying that
the companies
at least most companies that i have
dealt with
already have existing um
policies for that
and what this does is basically say that
this kind of that kind of harassment
won't be tolerated and that it will be
dealt with with the same
in the same way that other
discrimination and harassment is dealt
with
and so i'd like to ask the committee
to support this bill and
i'll take questions
thank you for your testimony
questions representative proud
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative take my question would
you see this bill as preventing a
employer having a policy of requiring
employees to take a breathalyzer at the
start of a shift
no i would not actually if if you can uh
test the breathalyzer without
without being intrusive on it i would
not say that
um so
i guess i'm fortunate in life i haven't
had much experience with breathalyzers
um
but from what i understand about them is
you normally you have to blow into a
straw and therefore you'd have to put
that straw in your mouth and looking the
definition of intrusive testing
i
wonder if that would end up on the
auspices of this bill or not
well the intent of the bill certainly
wasn't to do that um
if you see that as a problem i don't
have any problem with amending it so
that it would cover a situation like
that but
the intent of the bill is actually just
to limit the intrusive testing on people
thank you
thank you any additional questions
representative mandeville
yes thank you representative i i'd just
like to follow up on that question with
two other examples one being
a thermometer maybe put under the tongue
or a swab put into the nose like in the
common
test for covid that is being used now
would would either or both of those be
viewed as
entitled to an exemption per this
bill
both of those could absolutely be
entitled to an exemption under this
um
and in in reality with a thermometer
they have thermometers that do not
require that you place them under your
tongue
and as far as
that
penetration into a nose
yes that would be covered under it
thank you for your question
do you draw any distinction between the
deeper and the less deep penetration
with the swabs uh in this you said
intrusive and i'm just trying to get a
sense of
if you and i are talking about the same
thing as far as intrusive in that
respect is
no i no the the legislation is written
does not draw a distinction between
those two thank you thank you robert
vavalani
thank you mr chairman um thank you
representative taking the question
the so you're talking about blood tests
as well if a condition a pre-employment
condition is for a blood test that would
also be exempted yes thank you thank you
mr chairman
i wanted to make sure i heard your your
question correctly could you repeat it i
know you answered but i didn't quite
hear all the questions um
if this covered blood tests as a
pre-employment
and i'm sorry your answer representative
my answer was yes it would be covered
under this
so if i might ask a follow-up to that
representative avaloni
thank you
many uh
companies that have drivers
or have any individuals that work on a
job site or in a manufacturer they have
rules
and protocols that if there is an
accident whether they get hurt
themselves or in a vehicle accident they
will be tested for drugs and alcohol and
that can be that can be done either as a
blood test
or such and and
i'm concerned that that would
be caught under under this
was that your intent in any way
well it would be caught but uh there are
alternative ways of testing if someone
was to object to the test and this is
all based on
um someone actually saying uh no i want
an exemption to that versus you know um
like i said there are other tests that
can be done
thank you are there any other questions
for the representative
senion thank you for testifying today
thank you
i still don't see dave juve
no dave's
tired
paula minihan new hampshire hospital
association
yeah he told me earlier he wasn't
feeling well he might leave so just
wanted to make sure we hadn't come back
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee my name is paula minihan
senior vice president state government
relations with the new hampshire
hospital association representing all
our hospitals we are opposed to 15
1358 excuse me
we support an employee's right to
require vaccinations or periodic
screening testing as a condition of
employment and
chairman chairman i made the same note
that you did relative to drug testing
because i think this this
this bill does contemplate um or would
allow for an exemption for drug testing
which i think is um is
even more concerning
there's a process employers require
employees to follow if they choose to
apply for an exemption and if they are
granted an exemption the employee
may be required to get tested
periodically among other precautions
required by the employer this is a
decision an employee agrees to make as a
condition of continued employment
the bill is drafted includes the term
conscientious objectior as well as a
definition of intrusive testing
compelling organizations that choose to
require covid19 vaccinations or testing
for their employees to permit anyone who
objects to the vaccine or testing on the
grounds of personal conscience or prior
recovery from covid would render any
vaccine or testing requirement moved
putting in patients and staff at greater
risk of illness or death we are opposed
to 1358 and we urge the committee to
find this bill in expedient to legislate
and thank you for the opportunity to
provide comments
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions in the presenter
sitting down thank you very much
i have no other pink cards
hospital 1358 is there anyone else who
would like to speak
seeing none thank you very much i close
the hearing on house bill 13
58 we will resume
at 2 30 house bill 1377
so you folks have 30 minutes if you need
to
take care of business thank you very
much i'll be hanging out here
that's right
so
you know
foreign
we'll be talking
uh
this is
i just got to
bring him a card
my mailbox
i'll put it on here
just
because
you
and the speakers
i don't think
oh
you
you know archers
uh
um
is
mechanism
um
is
prevailing
does he work for a construction company
that's fine
once you said
and that's impressive
uh
what fascinates me about it is
right
like
what facts
is
here we go
over there
foreign
under control
we'll have to double check
foreign
mario
is representative condos here
is that how you say it c-o-n-t-o-i-s-s
okay
yeah but
they got to introduce the bill here
oh okay
i just mentioned her name if you didn't
acknowledge
representatives please take your seats
229. my mom is watching
representative i took spanish and not
french
contour
representative
contour from belknap you recognize
introduce house bill 33
1377.
mr chair of the honorable committee
memphis of the committee
i'm representative barbara compton from
belmont 7
i am here today to introduce hb 1377
relative to unemployment benefits
this bill is being brought about due to
a change in employment requirements that
were instituted after the employee was
hired
we all have reasonable expectations when
we go to work for
an employer
these expectations are spelled out at
the time of higher
however
due to government mandates midstream
employees are having to make difficult
life choices and some are being forced
out of their positions for
non-compliance
folks who have worked with the companies
for over 20 years are being pushed out
and being denied religious and medical
exemptions
doctors are not giving out medical
exemptions even if they know it is in
the best interest of the patient due to
a backlash in the medical community
yesterday i heard testimony that a woman
who got bell's palsy from a flu shot
and has to be careful regarding the
ingredients and what is put into her
body
has refused a mandated vaccine because
she cannot get a list of the ingredients
her doctor refused
to give her the medical exemption due to
the backlash
and thus she was forced to leave her job
this is only one example but there are
many many others
encountering this situation
through no fault of their own folks are
losing their jobs and they have no
recourse it is up to us at the state
level to assist folks with a helping
hand until they can get on their feet
asking for an additional six months of
unemployment benefits is not
unreasonable in my opinion
we are talking about loyal employees who
are forced out because they are doing
what is best for their health
monday night at my county meeting we
heard from the new nursing home director
that 11 people
may lose their job
for non-compliance due to the federal
mandate on february 15th
we also heard that an additional 60 of
the staff
would lose their job march 15th if they
make booster a part of being fully
vaccinated
what are these folks to do
i also heard
that the vendors
employees are being turned away and
those that do serve the nursing home can
now charge higher prices
on a personal note
a close family member passed away within
40 hours 48 hours after receiving her
second vaccine
the daughter who is a kind caring person
anguished for months over whether to
take the vaccine so she continued to
help others
and in the end she took the vaccine
but the psychological toll it took on
her was unnerving
had she opted not to take the vaccine
she would have no income i'm open to
questions
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for the representative
representative avalani
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question um you put this
under 275
would this be better under 282 for
unemployment insurance
um thank you for the question and i
relied on ols
for their expertise in this matter thank
you thank you
any additional questions
representative sullivan represented
followed by representative mandeville
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i understand the desire to have someone
get unemployment benefits and if if you
um voluntarily resign
not really voluntarily it could be
argued that someone who refuses to take
a vaccination has voluntarily desi
resigned because they could have
kept their job if they got the vaccine i
understand your point in letting them
get the workers comp
what i'm curious about is why they would
get an additional six months
beyond what
anyone else is unemployed would get
well thank you for the question
representative
uh first off this has nothing to do with
workers comp this is strictly
unemployment
thank you sorry and the other thing is
is that there was a contractual
agreement
between an employer an employee when
they started working there and nowhere
in that did it say that they had to take
a mandated vaccine
so they have changed their practices
midstream and i think it is unfair for
employ
employer employees who have worked for a
company and been loyal to them
to be out on the street because they are
doing what is best for their health and
their family and
not only that is it's the psychological
damage and the toll it takes on these
folks too so an additional six months i
think is very reasonable
what was it manifold
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
following up on representative
sullivan's question i wonder if
you would have any concern
that
enacting this bill
would
create
problems
keeping
staff
in places especially
such as nursing homes or health
facilities which are struggling with
staffing anyway
but other places as well
where
there would be this opportunity created
to get a kind of a windfall of sorts an
extra six months by simply saying i'm
not
being vaccinated even if they might
otherwise want to or been vaccinated
well thank you for the question
representative and i'll go back to when
we gave unemployment to anybody that
just claimed that they were afraid to go
to work for covet and then an additional
six hundred dollars per month which put
a hardship on businesses
however collecting unemployment benefits
is not a substitute for your at regular
check it is only a portion of that and
is only to help
so no i don't see that as an issue
representative
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative for taking my question um
would this bill change at all um who is
eligible for unemployment upon
termination uh for
not receiving a
vaccination requirement because i
believe we've previously heard testimony
that
the
department of labor only
considers it if it wasn't directly job
related so they said health care workers
wouldn't be eligible
but most other workers were would this
change that at all
thank you for the question
so
i'll just relate a personal experience
i had the opportunity to go work for a
hospital at one point but they told me
that i would have to receive the flu
shot every year which i opted out of
so i did not take that job so
we're talking about
people collecting
most businesses do not require you to
take a mandated flu shot or any other
vaccine
to work at their place of employment
and
under this because they're such
controversial and it was an emergency
and experimental
vaccine
i i think it calls into question
especially
in the fact that you cannot even get a
list of ingredients folks do not even
know if they're allergic to anything
and we're seeing a lot of side effects
due to this and i think people need to
be able to look out for their health
because without your health nothing else
really matters
thank you
any additional questions for the
representative
cena thank you very much thank you i'd
like to call on richard lavers
from the new employment securities
followed by
paula minihan
good afternoon mr chairman good
afternoon members of the committee nice
to see you all this is the
different setting that i'm used to
coming before you but nice to see
everyone
just for the record richard lavers
deputy commissioner of the new hampshire
department
of employment security
um
i have i do have some material that i
could hand out mr chairman uh with
regard to the department's approach to
claims
for individuals that are separated from
employment as a result of an employer's
vaccine policy i'll hand that out
and then
talk over a few points
and then take
all the questions from the committee and
certainly talk through
the issues on the material that i'm
going to provide to you as well
all right thank you mr chairman um so
first and foremost the department
as we customarily do with policy matters
that come before this committee the
department is neutral with regard to the
bill that we're currently considering
i do
need to note that the
unemployment compensation advisory
council which is
independent and separate from the
department
that they did take a position in
opposition
to this bill when they met this past
monday
that was a four to nothing
vote
chairman infantine is a member of that
committee that counsel
on behalf of the house of
representatives he did abstain from that
but
the chair of that committee lee nyquist
did ask that i make sure that the
committee was aware that they had taken
a position in opposition to this bill
but again
the council is separate and distinct
from the department the department is
neutral
as we do with all
matters that
potentially impact the unemployment
program in the state the department has
submitted this bill to the u.s
department of labor
and has requested that they review
the proposal for purposes of compliance
and conformity with federal requirements
members of this committee
can remember
some prior legislation that we've gone
through that same
process on
we don't have a response yet from the
u.s department of labor certainly as
soon as we do have that response we'll
make that available
to chairman infantine
and members of the committee so you can
review that and ask any associated
questions
based upon some recent opinions that we
have gotten back from u.s department of
labor
on some recent matters that this
committee has dealt with
i do suspect
that they may take issue
with some of the provisions
in this bill particularly
with the proposal to provide an
additional six months
of unemployment benefits uh to a
screw up the microphone as i adjusted
here
but with their the proposal to provide
an additional six months of benefits to
a particular group
of people claiming unemployment
what we have seen
most recently i believe we were in the
2019 time period
might have been 2018
representative sullivan you remember uh
quite clearly when we were dealing with
the bus driver issue
and there was a proposal that came
before this committee
to ease the work search requirements
for bus drivers
um it was a way they felt that it would
help retain more of their workforce
back then as they do now they were
struggling to have enough drivers
so that bill would have eased work
search requirements but only for one
particular group
um us department of labor got back to
the state and said
that
treating one group differently than the
others
for purposes of a requirement for
eligibility
ran counter to their equal treatment
provision
now they didn't tell the state that you
couldn't do this that's not how they
operate
with us what they did was they told us
that it would if enacted it would have
caused new hampshire to be out of
compliance and conformity with federal
requirements
what that means is that if we're found
out of compliance we lose our
administrative funding for the
unemployment program uh that's about 30
million dollars a year
and if we're out of conformity that
means that employers in the state no
longer get to take their 90 tax credit
against their federal tax obligation for
unemployment tax purposes that's about a
200 million a year
hit for new hampshire business so at the
time they came back and said if you
treat these workers differently than
others for purposes of eligibility
that would cause a conformity issue
the legislature in response to that
and i'm sure other
matters that they were considering
changed that bill
and made it so that anybody
on a temporary layoff of a defined
duration
originally they were looking at nine
weeks ultimately they ended up at 11
weeks but anyone on a temporary layoff
with a with a certain return date to
that employer
would then be
would not have to deal with work search
requirements as a as a
matter of continued eligibility
department of labor u.s department of
labor was fine with that we weren't
treating
the bus drivers or anyone else any
differently it was everyone that found
themselves in that situation
so i bring that up just to point out
that with the proposed uh bill here
that with proposing to provide an
additional six months of benefits to
certain
individuals based on their type of
separation from employment that could be
a cause of concern but again i'm not the
u.s department of labor i just wanted to
bring that to your attention when we do
get that opinion back from them we'll
certainly make that
available um
looking at our
current policy that we have
with regard to
eligibility for unemployment benefits
in situations
like this where we have an employer that
has a requirement for vaccination
i can give you some numbers on what
we've seen
since about september
talk a little bit about
the origins of that policy
and then certainly answer questions
so
since
our
materials
were first published back in
on our website back in september
the materials that you have in front of
you with the the frequently asked
questions
those were posted to our website we've
had about 134
claims for unemployment benefits
so
situations where someone has filed for
unemployment
and the reason that they are no longer
working
is related to a vaccine requirement from
the employer
now that is not the full universe of
people that have left employment in new
hampshire i am sure
but it is the universe of people that
have left employment and have filed for
unemployment benefits so 134 individuals
to date 70 7-0 of those claims have been
denied 30 percent have been allowed
when we look within particular sectors
the health care sector has been the the
dominant
uh sector from which people have
separated and filed for unemployment
we've had 92 of those 134 claims have
been within health care employers
and of those 92 claims from individuals
last employed by a health care employer
that's hospitals but also ambulatory
health other medical type employers
we've had 90
of those have been denied
so again total 134 claims filed thus far
for people that have left for those
types of reasons and have filed for
unemployment
uh 70 denied
of that 92 have been within health care
and those health care claims 90
of those have been denied so
getting into the
approach that the department takes
to these types of situations
first and foremost we very much respect
the at will nature private sector
employment here in the state
so when we implement a policy in looking
at
a claim for unemployment benefits where
someone has
violated an employer policy we're not
telling the employer that they can't
have that policy
we are simply looking at it and looking
at new hampshire supreme court case law
most specifically the sweepstakes
decision issued back in 1988 in the
progeny of cases that have come from
that decision and looking to see whether
or not the employer's policy is
reasonable under the circumstances
so again not telling the employer they
can't have that policy but what we are
doing is looking at it to see whether or
not the individual qualifies for
unemployment benefits and whether that
policy is reasonable under the
circumstances
so reasonableness is really a function
of the context in which
the policy is applied
context here is going to be the sector
in which that policy is being applied so
with
specifically with a vaccination
requirement
if we're talking about a health care
employer
charged with providing care to
our most frail and vulnerable citizens
health care employers are
considered to be acting reasonably with
a strict vaccination requirement because
of the circumstances under which they
find themselves in the services that
they provide
largely provided care to a vulnerable
population so a health care employer
with that interpretation would be
allowed to have a strict requirement
require vaccination of
its employees they need to consider
medical and religious grounds for
exception to that policy
but if someone
refused to comply
did not
meet
the grounds for a medical or religious
exemption to that policy they would not
be eligible for unemployment benefits in
that healthcare context
now moving outside of healthcare
in
hospitality in retail
office environments
where we're not dealing with an employer
that's providing care
to a frail and vulnerable population
employers that are outside of healthcare
if they were to implement a strict
policy
only
where they required vaccination did not
allow any alternatives alternatives
being
an employee agreeing to testing and
masking protocol
that they required vaccination and we're
outside of health care that individual
that separates from that employer
is likely to be eligible for
unemployment benefits
now
if that non-health care employer
has a flexible policy where they require
vaccination but
those employees that choose not to be
vaccinated they allow them
to comply with testing
and
masking alternatives to that vaccination
requirement
and someone still
quits that employment or is fired for
refusing to comply with that flexible
policy
they would likely not be eligible for
unemployment benefits
but again employer needs to consider
any medical or religious grounds for
that employee not being able to comply
when it comes to
medical grounds for being unable to
comply with a vaccine policy requirement
we look towards the medical community
for that individuals provide us with
medical documentation
from their provider
that's largely what we look at for
determining whether or not the
individual has met that medical
exception to that policy and whether
they are eligible for unemployment not
that they have to be rehired by the
employer mind you but whether they're
eligible for unemployment right
when it comes to religious grounds we
look to make sure that the employer has
considered
a request for a religious exception
from that individual
and then as long as the employer has
considered it
it was timely raised by the individual
then we defer to the employer's decision
with regard to that request for a
religious exception
we see a lot of variation
within a very small universe of claims
with 134 claims thus far
but that is largely an overview of how
we approach it based upon
at will nature of private sector
employment in the state
and based upon the decisions issued by
the new hampshire supreme court going
back to our sweepstakes decision which
looked at
the ability of an employer to enact a
policy and whether or not individuals
who are unable to comply or violate that
whether they're going to be eligible for
unemployment benefits
and that's how we've approached these
cases and the document that was
circulated i hope there was enough for
all members of the committee but that
provides some
some frequently asked questions some
common scenarios that we try to hope to
illustrate the approach that we've taken
so i'll stop with that and i can
certainly
answer any questions
from the members
thank you
uh just for sure you're aware mr deputy
commissioner i did provide the committee
with the powerpoint presentation you
provided to the committee outlining the
number of claims and etcetera so they
are a little familiar with that i did
see a few hands representative seaworth
followed by sullivan
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your
testimony
something i'm and maybe you can clarify
if it's too big a question maybe we can
take it offline but where i'm getting
a little confused in the gray area so
i'm an employer i'm unhappy with
my
employee's
work product and i say i can't employ
you anymore
and i fire him it would seem he's almost
certainly eligible for unemployment
under such a circumstance on the other
hand
and trying to generalize from this
vaccine if i say
my employee is not complying
with
what i've laid out as the requirements
for employment here
then it goes into this test are are my
requests reasonable and he may or may
not be able to
be eligible for unemployment and it
seems to me there's there's some gray
area in between there where what's the
difference between
poor performance and not meeting my
requirements of the employee can you
maybe in a little easier way than my
question was phrase kind of explain
the difference between those two
circumstances and just for clarification
i know that representative turcotte
would be a stellar employee so
i know that you aren't referring to his
work performance
so when we get into your ability to do
the job
right the your ability to do the job and
if you're fired for being unable to do
the work
you are in almost all cases going to be
eligible for unemployment benefits
really you're
you unfortunately maybe got hired into a
position for which you
just you overshot
and then couldn't do the work
we do not
um or rather when when it comes to
ability
and your lack thereof you're going to be
eligible
on the other hand
compliance with an employer policy
is a different circumstance
under which you would find yourself
potentially unemployed
and when we when we look again at
employer policies vaccination is a
employer policy in this case
we look to see
the reasons why an employer has either a
strict or a flexible policy
with regard to a vaccination requirement
and then again we look to see the
context in which that employer is
operating
there could be a scenario where a
non-healthcare employer
might be dealing with a vulnerable
clientele
they might decide to have a strict
vaccination requirement but they're
outside of the health care
sector
and they might be able to justify
the strict requirement
and then someone that does not comply
with that
might find themselves ineligible for
unemployment
in each and every one of these cases and
i'll just stress that again in each and
every single one of these unemployment
cases
dealing with a vaccination requirement
as we do with all separation decisions
we talk with the individual filing for
unemployment
and we talk with the employer
so we go through a fact-finding process
we get as much information relevant to
that separation as we can get from both
of them oftentimes it involves us going
back and forth
to each of them to ask additional
questions and based upon the information
that we get from both sides then
applying that within the context of the
four corners of our policy we determine
whether or not that individual is
eligible
all of these claims
are then
with the attention that the department
provides to this area we meet regularly
on a weekly basis we're reviewing claims
that are coming in
we're looking at the the circumstances
under which these claims are being filed
and we're making sure that the decisions
are being issued consistent with the
policy but each and every case each side
has an opportunity
to explain the decision that was made
president of sullivan followed by
abalone and
then cahill thank you mr
chairman
and thank you rich for taking
mr uh
uh
deputy commissioner um
you explained in detail what the
six-month issue um might
entail with the u.s department of labor
but as i read this
this
bill does not appear to make someone
automatically eligible because they're
fired over covet
reasons so it seems that the criteria
that you're talking about now would
still apply is that your understanding
and that's a very good question
represented
in the department's reading of this bill
where
it does not specifically state that an
individual will be automatically
eligible
in this circumstance the department
would still be applying its existing
policy that we've detailed today
it does require though if someone is
found eligible in that circumstance they
would then receive an additional six
months of benefits
one item to point out with that regard
is
the bill does
when it when it comes to the financing
of those benefits
unemployment compensation financing
there's a handful of us in the state
that probably think it's an interesting
topic all employers think it's
interesting every quarter though i can
guarantee you that because employers pay
for the unemployment compensation system
the trust fund is built of dollars paid
by new hampshire
employers
so during the pandemic in state
unemployment benefits we paid out about
350 million dollars that came out of our
trust fund that was made up of tax
payments from new hampshire business
so if we are talking about providing an
additional six months of benefits to any
individual
that is paid by new hampshire employers
the bill says that
this would get funded by either
employers
or the department
for purposes here of unemployment comp
financing we are one in the same
the dollars that get paid out in a claim
are dollars that the employer has paid
into the fund
so
an important point to remember is that
if we're increasing the duration of
eligibility we're increasing the dollars
that are coming out of the trust fund
and depending on how that is structured
it's either going to cause
a negative
effect on an employer's experience which
causes their tax rate to go up
or if it's direct charge to the trust
fund then it's going to lower the
balance in the trust fund thus delaying
the time that employers get their fund
balance reductions to their tax rate
and that's for our for-profit employers
our non-profit employers
our hospitals
and other non-profits they are largely
reimbursing employers it's important
that we remember them
that means that they pay back to the
fund dollar for dollar for every benefit
that goes up
so
the um
92 claims that we had from the health
care sector
if those claims that were rejected were
paid and we paid an additional six
months of benefits
those are employers that are reimbursers
they pay back dollar for dollar they
would have to pay back to the fund for
those benefits
if those individuals were paid for that
full enhanced duration of
26 weeks plus an additional
six months so for a full year
you're looking at about a 1.2 million
dollar
charge
to our health care employers in the
state
now
with our for profits it's calculated
differently but in each and every case
there would be an impact on that
employer's experience in their tax rate
but again
it all comes down to
with unemployment comp financing this is
not
financed by the general fund this is not
financed separately from the department
or the federal government this is paid
for by
our employers both for-profit and
non-profit in the state
follow up
thank you
thank you for that answer you're always
very detailed
you've covered
roman one in the bill fairly clearly um
could you speak to roman two and three
with regard to the 14 days
to file a um
the court hearing within 14 days
in the recovery of
costs and legal fees to
see how that compares to the
department's current practices
uh so thank you representative so
i would have to defer to the
sponsor on
roman two
on the bill
there might be a different intent
with regard to an expedited court here
and i'm not sure what the sponsor is
referring to there
and with making the change to
rsa 275 and not 282a there might be a
different intent
however the
the structure of
appeals for unemployment compensation
purposes
we largely are administrative appeals
until an individual gets up to the new
hampshire supreme court
so
if you apply for benefits and receive a
decision that you disagree with you
appeal that decision to the department
we have an internal appeals unit you
have a hearing that's right now going to
be remote either on zoom or going to be
on telephone
and you have your opportunity to make
your case to why you should be eligible
if you disagree with that decision you
then have another layer of
administrative review that you can take
that you can take advantage of
then have another layer to our appeals
board so a separate
body but administratively attached to
the department
they then refuse to review that decision
and then ultimately if you disagree with
that you can take that to a
discretionary review to the new
hampshire supreme court so
knowing what our appeal structure looks
like
i'm not sure what the intent there is
with roma 2 but i would i would
defer to the the sponsor to want to
explain that further
all right representative avalani
followed by cahill
mr clerk did you want to ask a question
or do you have a question mr clerk
john
did you want to ask about something
there or you just want to be in line to
ask a question
all right
avalani cahill
thank you mr chairman thank you deputy
commissioner this is going to dovetail
very nicely into what representative
sullivan asked
say there was an additional six months
that was
added to the unemployment for certain
mandated
policies how would you quantify the
unemployment trust fund and the cost to
employers
and you've already explained the profit
nonprofit with the unemployment fund
need to be larger with the cost to
employers need to be more in order to
cover that
possible possibility of having one
year's unemployment
yeah thank you for that question so
it
i can say with certainty that it would
be a further
drain on the unemployment trust fund
because we're talking about additional
benefits that have to come out of the
trust fund there is not another source
for those payments
so that would be additional dollars
coming out of the trust fund
and for employers that are involved in
those separations it would be a negative
impact on their tax rate their tax rate
is determined by
their experience with the unemployment
system so we look at taxes paid in and
then we look at benefits paid out to
your former employees and so that would
be an addition that would be additional
benefits that would be charged against
that employer's experience your
experience then determines what your
rate is going to be which statutory
table within 282 a you find yourself
so the more you pay in in taxes the less
we pay up benefits to your employees the
lower your rate
right now average
for-profit
employer tax rate in the state is
already back to 1.6
even though we just paid 176
000 people or about 25 of new
hampshire's workforce unemployment
benefits over the last two years
so employer tax rates have come down
surprisingly fast
much faster than they did during the
great recession
as you remember those rates stagnated up
in the the three percent
and plus range for a few years
following uh that 2010
2011 period
so employers would see a negative
negative impact
on their tax rates because we're looking
at
additional benefits being paid out
that the balance in the trust fund
determines when employers get reductions
to their rates
the legislature in
part of the
it was part of the trailer bill
the last budget made some changes to
that
right now employers get a reduction to
their tax rate when the fund equals or
exceeds 250 million dollars for a full
quarter
the fund right now is at 194 million
dollars
we project that the fund will be at that
250 million dollar mark by the fourth
quarter of this year
it's pretty close remember you have to
maintain that balance
at at least 250
for the full quarter but right now our
forecast shows that 0.5 reduction to
employer tax rates triggered by that 250
million dollar balance being reached
being realized for employers in the
first quarter of 2023 the most expensive
quarter for employers in the state and
less those that have a seasonal pattern
to their employer
the
next trigger that employers get a full 1
reduction to their rate is at 350
million and then a the maximum rate
reduction of 1.5 percent kicks in at 400
million and to put those rate reductions
into perspective to perspective so it's
a 0.5 reduction a 1 reduction in a one
and a half percent reduction a new
employer coming into new hampshire
starts with a two point seven percent
rate they pay 2.7 percent on the first
14 000 in annual wages per employee so
when you start talking about 0.5
1.0 and a 1.5 reduction it's a
significant reduction for that rate that
an employer finds themselves at and
right now we're at about a 1.6
average tax rate across all private
sector employers
representative cahill followed by
representative mackey
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
lavers for uh
explaining the impact potential impact
of this bill uh for
private employers particularly the
hospitals
what about public employers can you
speak up a little bit mike i'm sorry
what about how would this affect public
employers i'm assumed that they would
also be you know participating in this
and shouldn't it be a fiscal note
to uh to explain that to us
so thank you for that question so public
employers in the state they are as you
noted
participants in the unemployment
compensation system
so
the state as an employer is a required
reimbursement
so employees last employed by the state
that qualify for unemployment benefits
the state then reimburses the trust fund
dollar for dollar for those payments
our
municipalities and our county employers
and our school districts
they
can elect to either be a reimburser
and only pay
to the trust fund when they have an
individual that qualifies for benefits
but when they do pay its dollar for
dollar like the example i said of
non-profit hospitals
but they have the choice they could
elect to be a tax-paying employer like a
for-profit employer and in that case
they would pay quarterly with a rate
based upon their experience largely your
public employers
the last time i looked for your local
public county and school districts
about 90 percent of them elect to
reimburse and not be a tax bank employer
but yes they do participate in the
unemployment compensation system they
would be impacted by any change to
eligibility or change and duration
benefits
and all of this is based on really
something that developed that neither
the employer nor the employee could
predict
how one would respond to a situation i
know in healthcare people expect that
they have to take all the vaccines as
they come up
but
you would have no idea whether you had
an employee who would be averse to
taking a vaccine that was recommended
you're sort of at no fault of that fault
correct and we would look you know we
would regardless of whether or not the
individual applying is coming from a
public sector employer or a private
sector employer we would look at
the circumstances of the separation
representative mackey
followed by representative mendeville
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um the representative
said earlier that
it was a legitimate reason to turn down
employment if you're afraid of covid
is that true
represent just to make sure i heard that
the question is
whether or not it would be a legitimate
reason to turn down employment because
of fear of
coping 19. yes
so
with right now
the only
program
for unemployment benefits
in the state of new hampshire is our
regular state unemployment program
so
if you are
unemployed through no fault of your own
and you have
qualifying earnings
from your prior four quarters
you may be eligible for benefits
but
the reasons that we saw for unemployment
during
and 2021 with individuals were
able to apply for benefits
because they were unable to go into the
workplace due to concerns around coven
those reasons that were articulated in
the cares act that program is gone new
hampshire has not been a participant in
that program since june of 21 it expired
for all states in september of 21
so
an individual
leaving employment i guess would be
in in this in the scenario that you
described
someone leaving just because of a fear
of covid
that would largely be looked at as a
voluntary quit but we might be looking
at some medical issues
that the employer would certainly have
to consider if there were an
accommodation issue so that situation
could get complicated pretty quickly
well
i'll follow up uh
i understand that is no longer the case
but that was the case where people were
especially fearful of coburn
with the recent increase in adverse
reactions and the reporting of adverse
reactions
wouldn't it be somewhat hypocritical to
not allow fear of the vaccine also to be
used in the same way as the fear of
coving was during the peak of the
outbreak
um if there were a desired change to
state eligibility for unemployment
benefits
the department very much respects
this committee's role in the
legislature's role in setting policy so
if that were a
decision made by this body we would
certainly
implement it as
as it was enacted
thank you
where was it minimal thank you mr
chairman i i noted in your
frequently asked questions as a
reference to employers
vaccine mandate so i see you've
considered it
and in the proposed
[Music]
bill
the
subject matter
is
where there's non-compliance with an
employer-mandated
vaccination requirement we've heard
questions in the committee before about
whether something that was mandated by
the federal government say
was not necessarily an
employer-mandated
vaccination so for example in the
context of the
federal health care
mandate
which has been
ruled permissible
would you read this
legislation if it went through as
applying or not applying in that context
so that's a very good question
fortunately
the department works very closely
with attorney general from ella
and his office
with questions like the one you've
described where we could potentially
have a federal and state
inconsistency
um if if we were confronted with that
would we know with the the federal rule
being uh currently upheld
uh for um employers that receive
medicare and medicaid funds
um and we had a different
requirement uh we would certainly seek
counsel from the attorney general's
office and it might be something that we
were seeking opinions from
the u.s department of labor as well
thank you
assuming that this
did apply
to such circumstances
would you have
an enlarged concern about the
non-compliance issue you started with in
your testimony where the federal
government had mandated
a vaccine rule
and our
statutes were
changing the application of the
unemployment benefit
contrary to what was
came out of that federal mandate
it would certainly
uh that situation if you know an
employer required
to have a vaccination policy in that
context that would certainly
be considered a way towards the
reasonableness of that employer's policy
when we look at the circumstances that
someone would find themselves in filing
for unemployment benefits but it would
certainly way in favor of the
reasonableness of that policy
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you again
deputy commissioner um given the
cost factors across multiple
employers non-profit profit
public employees private employers could
you quantify
a financial note for us the cost of this
we can certainly
try to quantify those costs we would
there would have to be
some speculation obviously
with regard to the rate at which
individuals would file
but we can certainly quantify the cost
of those claims that we have received
that i had touched upon earlier with
those 134 claims and then the health
care claims and what that would have
cost to our health care employers if
they had all been required to be paid
and then paid an additional six months
but we can certainly do that
thank you mr chairman with the
chairman's approval of course
pardon with your approval of course yes
thank you
any further questions
representative cahill
thank you mr chair and uh thank you
again mr labors
reading reading the bill
you know to have discussed how you have
an appeals process
and you have criteria that you follow
and we agree we seem to be agreeing that
six months of extension
is perilous for our employers
is this bill necessary
representative and i would have to defer
to the committee on that one
thank you
any further questions
i have uh just one brief
the ten percent of the cases you did
approve of the
health care
was that because
the department felt
that the requirements from the employer
were unnecessary or unreasonable
so
with regard to the the 10
fallen within the health care sector
that have been allowed
a couple of different scenarios
that we've seen
one has been with
individuals that raised a religious
request for a religious exception
and employers allowing that
recognizing it but then being unable to
accommodate it
in those types of situations where the
employer again has done the due
diligence they've reviewed the
individual's request for that type of
exception to the vaccine requirement
they've granted it but are unable to
accommodate it we pay those individuals
unemployment benefits
another common situation that we've
we've seen in some of those that have
been payable
have been with individuals that are 100
remote
so
no plans
for bringing them back into the facility
and they are 100 remote worker but yet
perhaps for ease of administration and
the requirement
everyone
has been required to be vaccinated an
individual in that type of situation
would be found eligible because again
they are remote with no plans to be
brought in the facility so that's a
couple of examples that we've seen for
that
the small percentage of claims in the
health care sector that have been
payable
okay as a follow-up to representative
avaloni's question
in the past if you've seen
bills requiring extended
unemployment benefits to
municipalities in the state that are
self-funded in this case wouldn't you
normally see a financial note
it would it's unusual uh whether
not where there being a potential impact
to
local government
um
state government as well
that there wouldn't be a financial note
i would agree with you there but
it is a it's a challenging exercise to
calculate out that cost
again based on
what we'd be a lot of assumptions that
would need to be made
so we'd have to always approach any sort
of
fiscal cost for
local government with with regard to
that this particular requirement um we
would provide you with plenty of caveats
in that
fiscal note that we would submit but
again we would do our best
thank you very additional questions for
the deputy commissioner
see none thank you really appreciate it
i'll call paula minahan from the new
hampshire hospital association followed
by rason chester
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee paula minihan senior vice
president state government relations for
the new hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals the
hospital association is opposed to house
bill 1377
it is our position that employers have
the right to determine what is best for
their employees and their clients
patients and our patrons requiring
vaccinations of health care workers for
communicable diseases is not new for
hospitals in new hampshire and i think
it's important to note this bill is not
specific to covet so this would
definitely impact
hospitals hospitals have required
vaccination against several communicable
and deadly diseases such as mumps
measles rubella chickenpox dip theory of
tetanus pertussis and influenza as a
condition of employment with the same
types
of medical and religious exemptions
allowed for under covid19 vaccines we
believe it's absolutely the right to do
for the health and safety of our
patients our staff and citizens of new
hampshire and the vast majority of
hospital staff have been vaccinated
against covet and have received
exemptions and we've heard from many
health care workers who support the
vaccine requirement to protect their
health and that of patients one note i
need to state for the record the cdc.gov
faqs lists the ingredients of all the
vaccines and i just wanted to point that
out because it has been stated a couple
times and i think that was
incorrectly stated that the vaccine
ingredients are not available they're
absolutely available on the cdc.gov
website and i encourage anyone that is
curious to go on and see
the fact is that very very few
individuals as mr laver said have either
chosen to leave or have
due to with a hospital due to this
requirement and have relief of their
position and i think his data supports
that however this bill could cause a
perverse incentive to encourage
individuals to choose to not comply with
the employer's requirement to be
vaccinated further the bill before you
is not specific to back to covet as i
mentioned and that which causes
additional concerns and confusions for
employers due to the open end nature of
such a bill we also made note that we
thought we think this bill
doesn't have a fiscal note and should um
so that i think a number of you have
already identified that in addition um
it sounds like it would raise employer
taxes which is also really
troubling we're opposed to this bill and
we encourage this um the committee to
find it an expedient to legislate thank
you and i appreciate the time
happy to answer any questions thank you
any questions
well senator
thank you very much
miss chester when i mentioned your first
name your friend smiled have i been
mispronouncing your name all day
your first name have i even noticed what
is your how do you pronounce yourself
thank you thank you committee chair
thank you committee members um
i want to start by
letting you all know that the sponsor of
this bill was speaking of me
and um i just i'm going to keep it
really short i just wanted to let you
folks know if you have any questions for
me directly i am more than willing to
open to take questions the only thing i
want to point out is
the last uh speaker mentioned that the
cdc ingredients or the ingredients for
all three of the vaccines are on the cdc
website
um that is a partial truth
what is on the cdc website is the list
of active ingredients what is not on
there is the full list of inactive
ingredients
and
my allergy that they
that they determined was with regards to
an inactive ingredient that's found in a
lot of vaccines
so that's it and i'll take any questions
if anybody wants to ask any questions
for
resent
rasan
russan or san
sorry
seeing none thank you very much
i do not have any additional pink cards
for house bill
1377 is there anyone else here who would
like to speak
on the bill
seeing none thank you very much i closed
the hearing on this and we'll open the
hearing on house bill 1377.
i have to wait two minutes
on youtube
so you guys can't see this but there's a
computer screen here and i got this
goofy looking monkey
oh
yeah
mr abbott
all right it is now 3 30. we're going to
introduce house bill 1538 fnl
requiring prevailing wages on state
funded public work projects we did not
have anyone signed up to introduce the
bill vice chairman seaworth would you
please introduce
house bill 1538 fnl
of course mr chairman uh representative
seaworth representing pembroke in
chichester vice chairman of the labor
committee and i would like to introduce
house bill 1538
regarding prevailing wages on state
funded public works projects and i'll
say no more
thank you very much mr vice chairman
i call
mr gary abbott from the associated
general contractors
speaking opposition of the bill
thank you very much chairman committee
members for the record
my name is gary abbott i'm the executive
vice president of the associated general
contractors of new hampshire
i come to you today in opposition to
house bill 1538.
i will be right up front with you i was
hoping to hear from the sponsor the
reason why this bill was put in
in the sense of
what problems have we had that would
equate the necessity
of having this being put in for the
legislation but not able to have that
i'm going to tell you
i was involved this was a law
prior to 1985 in the state of new
hampshire
and it was repealed by the legislature
and the bottom line for that repeal was
the increase in costs
for construction projects
the lar applied to municipalities so
school building projects were affected
so legislators looked at
we don't need this extra cost we had a
project that was a million dollars more
when you added this kind of legislation
onto it mandating increased labor costs
that's what the davis bacon act does
it's a prevailing wage rate and a lot of
people don't understand it so today i'm
going to try to
give you my short version of 30 years of
seeing this type of bill before
think of it this way you have a
classification and i'm just going to say
carpenter or clerk or whatever and you
pay people
twenty dollars an hour thirty dollars an
hour and forty dollars an hour
how the davis bacon system works they do
a survey
and they take everybody with that same
classification with say it's a clerk
what they do is they average it so say
you had equal numbers of people in all
of those categories the prevailing wage
rate would be 30 dollars everybody
getting paid 20 now gets paid 30 as a
minimum
the 40 are still going to get paid 40.
you can see after 40 years of this act
every time they do a survey
the minimum was the last survey
so it continues to inflate
the amount of money it doesn't really go
by skill
it's the classification
i have made recommendations to the
federal legislation
to try to make it work for new hampshire
another big issue for new hampshire is
we don't have enough projects
in each county to set a rate
i think the fiscal note is way off i
don't think the department of labor has
any idea of how many classifications are
not going to be already have a wage rate
they're going to be swamped so how do
they
pick a wage rate when i have
let's say
i'll pick one that is in the current
federal program
guard rail
we have maybe three guard rail companies
in the state
if one company during the survey period
works in one county
they can't use that one company that's
not an average they have to have more
than one company to do the survey
so it comes out blank
so under this bill it goes to the
department of labor and they have to
come up with a wage rate
there's no procedures and there's no
right now if that were to happen
it goes to the federal government under
a whole process
which i can tell you contractors don't
like and they don't know what they're
going to get
for a wage rate because they're going to
look at surrounding counties and
surrounding counties maybe massachusetts
and suddenly the rate could come back
nowhere near what they're paying
and it doesn't mean they accept what
they've been paying in that county
on private jobs this is a big one
so
what i want you to get is this will add
cost even though this excludes schools
won't affect schools because it's been
excluded
which is great
but i think it's going to impact stake
projects the same way
so
you know i proposed i'm going to just
give you some my
wage rates shouldn't be just determined
the prevailing wage rate i think what
most legislators are looking for
is a minimum wage on a craft if you were
to do this for construction
but i've heard no problem with how much
contractors are already paying
and if you know the shortage and help
that we're currently having the biggest
weak problem we have is employees going
to whatever company pays the most that's
what's happening at the moment
so you have to understand that
so i'm highlighting this problem
the first thing i would say on this bill
don't adopt the federal
uh davis-bacon regulations
they haven't changed they only changed
it once since it was first put in place
they added fringe benefits that's it
to tell me a law that they enacted 50
years ago
works in today's environment i'm going
to tell you
it doesn't work for new hampshire maybe
it works for some big cities like
philadelphia but it doesn't work in the
little state of new hampshire we just
don't have that many projects that would
qualify
the other the other big issue
i get involved with the surveys
i'm encouraging contractors to fill out
the survey so we don't have wage rates
that come out through the davis bacon
that are way off
and
they have
so you have to understand they do it
every two three years they go around to
the different like they'll do building
and then they'll do highway they'll do
heavy
there's different classifications and
they do surveys in the state
let me just tell you the one that's up
right now
highway they surveyed
and the cutoff date was 2019.
they surveyed wage rates from november
of 2017
to 10 31 2018. so a year
1718.
they're still in the verification mode
do you think those rates are going to be
anything compared to what we just went
through this past year with inflation
and employee costs
so
the accuracy of the thing i also want to
explain
in some categories i've seen things like
a classification in my 30 years i've
never seen an oiler came up as a
classification
i don't remember an oiler ever being a
classification it was 85 bucks an hour
so i don't know who that is and who was
getting that
but somehow through this davis baking
process that came out as a wager
or we've had cases where a skill
like pipe layer is less than another
classification and there oh we had this
one a pipe layer was paid less than the
roller operator
guess what pipe layers want to do they
want to ride the roller
it clearly skill wise the pipe layer was
a much more expensive job but the rates
came out
different
try correcting a rate of tried
it's next to impossible through the
federal highways through the federal
davis bacon department of labor
they have their rules you really can't
change them this is what they've done
for years
so i really plead with you that this has
bill has come up since 1985 multiple
times and it hasn't made it into law
and i think cost is one thing and i'd
like to hear
you know who's not getting paid enough
in construction because
i've got companies that tell me if i
come to work for them for any one of
those trades i'm getting 25 bucks or
more per hour
in this economy so i'm looking for
why we need this if we do need something
my doors are open for our state but i
think under the fiscal note it's going
to cost the labor department more i
think the fiscal note should address
what the cost of construction projects
will be for the state
have you ever gone to the government
council with a construction project that
was 10 over budget
you're in trouble if you're the state
agency
what's it going to cost state agencies
to collect payrolls review them and make
sure everything's in compliance there's
a lot of costs to do this system
so i bring that up to you
it looks like
not many of us are
here in the i didn't expect to have reps
all by myself but
i appreciate the committees
glad to work with a subcommittee a
committee what we're trying to address
and the best way to do it because
i just don't know what the problem is
for this bill this year
and i would end my testimony and hope
the committee votes itl
thank you for your testimony questions
representative abalani followed by
representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question um there is no
fiscal note from the department of labor
sorry charlino i'm sorry i just can't
hear you uh there's no fiscal note from
the department of labor
it's only for administrative services
oh that's correct the administrative
services of the number of people they
may need
but i guess i was looking at how the
bill is drafted as
projects of public works so i'm not sure
if des's projects is
department safety projects which all run
through administrative services but
they're controlled by those agencies
you know what are those costs that would
be in place i also
i agree with you
at first i looked at it to see what the
municipal association was going to put
in
a fiscal note and i get it they didn't
put anything as their example
thank you mr chairman welcome
representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
my question is to ask if you can fill in
something i seem to remember from
earlier
discussions in this area you mentioned
a big problem in new hampshire is where
small state
representative projects are thin on the
ground
and doesn't provide data i also seem to
recall that these participating in the
survey is voluntary so you can have
very few of the participants actually
turn in the data
and
those that do may have
a particular agenda
so you get data that's naturally skewed
by the people submitting the surveys
right when we encourage people to submit
data
we're hoping for the private sector to
submit data but what is the incentive
for them to do it there's a lot of
paperwork involved in setting your
classification filling out these forms i
could bring them in for you
then the labor department the federal
labor department calls you up and wants
to verify
all of this information so right now
they're calling my contractors and
trying to verify
2017 data
i'm looking at it going
the rates back then now have no
correlation
and they only survey every three years
so the stuff's behind but you're
absolutely correct
the only ones that benefits are the ones
that are in the system that already have
the rate if they're too high
and so the agenda is for the high ones
to come in but i think there is a
i understand the philosophy but this
bill attaching it to a system that has
been problematic for new hampshire just
is the wrong thing to do if you wanted
to set up a system you might have to
have a division of the department of
labor and have a way for them to do
surveys or set rates and you would have
to figure out what's a fair formula
i think this process is just not the
correct for today but you're right
even the contractors that are
participating it's not necessarily that
they have an agenda but
they're stuck with whatever comes out
and how to deal with it for the next
three years and so they don't want to do
that either
any other questions for mr abbott
saying none thank you very much there's
no one else here in the hall
i saw him
uh there any other
show i'm going to close hearing on house
bill 1538 fnl i do have an announcement
for the committee members here
i'm going to establish a study uh
committee not a study committee a
subcommittee
for house bill 1088 12 10 13 51
1352 and 1358
all in 1377 all the code bills we heard
today they'll be chaired by
representative turcotte
representative abalone has volunteered
to be on that as well
representative sullivan and bouchard
have also agreed i do need one
additional individual if i don't get any
volunteers on the republican side i will
pick one
so um
anyone who's either listening or
whatever i'll try to pick one
and i will leave that up to
representative turcotte as to how
he's going to present
either a one bill or a couple bills or
what have
you okay
also please check your emails there are
some bills we will be exacting next week
we will be executing after
we're done with our
our bills for the day
and there will be some amendments on
some of those so please be ready to um
you know we've read them read them have
your questions ready
possibly to the sponsor of the
amendments beforehand representative
sullivan
um i was wondering if it might make
sense if we had downtime during the day
if we knew what bills were going to be
exact
if we could save some time at the end of
the day by executing some of the bills
in between the others
if i heard you correctly what um
you would like to know the bill numbers
so you can execute them possibly in
between bills if we have time is that
what you're asking representative
sullivan
well you've given us a list
and so
it just seems if we had one of those
half hour down times we could uh take up
one of the execs that we were
anticipating taking up at the end of the
day it might just move us along that's
all
that's fine um
as long as you're not cramming things in
there because i don't want to have a
half an hour period and have a piece of
legislation where there's going to be a
lot of debate on it so we'll take it as
we can i have no problem doing that as
long as everyone is going to be prepared
should one of those things come up
representative
thank you for volunteering for that
subject meeting are there any other
questions that will be left up to
representative terracott to
schedule a meeting
any other questions to the chair
thank you very much for your diligence
today and we have a couple more uh
longer ones coming up
longer days i would like to get have us
all be done in three weeks possibly
we do have to definitely exact a few
bills next week because they are
financial uh bills that have to go to
another committee
so
all right thank you very much everyone
have a great day
thank you sergeant-at-arms and all your
folks for keeping control
i know i'm getting deaf i know i need
hearing aids but um